je vous propose que nous commencions je
pense que
certains de nos collègues vont nous
rejoindre mais comme les QG ont fini
aujourd'hui un peu plus tard que
d'habitude peut-être qu'ils sont déjà
perdus dans les couloirs parce que comme
notre salle habituelle n'est pas
celle-là mais une autre salle à mon avis
les réflexes sont faits qui sont montés
dans la salle de 145 et je pense qu'ils
vont réaliser assez rapidement et
surtout regarder leur convocation
mes chers collègues nous recevons
aujourd'hui des dirigeants des quatre
entreprises de l'audiovisuel public
national pour évoquer les avenants au
contrat d'objectifs et de moyens
proposés par le gouvernement pour 2023
je remercie donc pour leur présence
madame Delphine Ernotte présidente de
France Télévisions madame sylvieille
présidente de Radio France madame
Marie-Christine Saragosse présidente de
France médiumonde et Monsieur Laurent
Vallet président de l'Institut national
de l'audiovisuelle société bien connue
dans le Val-de-Marne
je précise que Bruno patineau président
d'artefrance est retenu à Strasbourg
pour une réunion du conseil
d'administration du GE d'Arte
j'ajoute pour expliquer l'absence de TV5
Monde que la chaîne francophone compte
tenu de son statut international ne
dispose pas de comme mais d'un document
spécifique cette audition intervient
dans un contexte particulier marqué
concernant les moyens de l'audiovisuel
public par la suppression de la
contribution à l'audiovisuel public
l'été dernier et sont remplacement au
moins jusqu'à la fin de 2024 par
l'attribution d'une part de TVA aussi
société de l'audiovisuel public la
question du financement de ces
entreprises restons couvertes et on ne
peut pas considérer que le gouvernement
s'est acquitté en tout cas à ce stade de
sa promesse de réformer le financement
d'audiovisuel public compte tenu des
incertitudes qui subsistent je saisis
l'occasion de cette rencontre pour
réaffirmer l'attachement de la
commission de la culture du Sénat à ce
que les entreprises de l'audiovisuel
public bénéficient d'une ressource
suffisante prévisible et protéger des
régulations budgétaires cette ressource
des graines est une des conditions de
son indépendance de son bon
fonctionnement et donc de son adaptation
au nouveau enjeux et notamment les
enjeux numérique le Sénat travaille
depuis de longues années sur la
transformation de notre audiovisuel
public notre commission a fait de
nombreuses propositions pour accompagner
les évolutions nécessaires encore
dernièrement à l'occasion d'un rapport
réalisé conjointement avec la commission
des finances par nos collègues Jean
Raymond Higonnet et Roger carochi nos
propositions ont toujours eu pour
objectif de renforcer l'audiovisuel
public et de définir des objectifs
ambitieux c'est la raison pour laquelle
les précédents comme adoptés pour la
période
2019-2022 nous était apparu comme
décevant il en est évidemment de même
des avenants que nous examinons
aujourd'hui qui prolonge simplement les
comme d'une année
nous souhaitons néanmoins vous entendre
sur ces avenants et leur objectif pour
2023 mais nous attendons aussi que ces
échanges nous permettent de mieux
évaluer les difficultés qui sont les
vôtres à la veille d'une année 2023 qui
sera comme 2022 marqué du saut de
l'inflation et aussi des effets de la
préparation de la réforme de de la
contribution audiovisuel public qui vous
a rendu éligible par exemple à la taxe
sur les salaires sans que cela n'ait été
prévu les questions de mes collègues
nous permettront également d'évoquer les
enjeux d'avenir comme un cycle les
objectifs qui pourraient figurer dans
les comme 2024 2028 pour lequel le
gouvernement va a commencé à
travailler notamment avec certains
groupes de travail après une
intervention liminaire je vous propose
de limiter environ 7 minutes puisque
vous êtes 4 et faire en sorte que nous
puissions par la suite vous vous posez
des questions le premier à poser des
questions sur un autre rapporteur
pour l'audiovisuel j'aurais mon Hugonnet
qui posera chacun d'entre vous une
première question et puis dans la foulée
bien sûr chacun chacun des sénateurs ou
sénatriculé souhaitera pourra également
interunir je précise enfin que cette
audition est captée est diffusée en
direct sur le système internet du Sénat
et sans plus tarder je vous donne la
parole je crois que je commençais par
madame la Présidente de France
Télévisions si d'accord
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je suis très heureuse de cette
échange avec votre commission à
l'occasion de l'examen de notre Avenant
du COM alors tout d'abord je voudrais
dire que
l'avenant qui vient de s'écouler
apporter en lui un plan de
transformation très ambitieux et
respecté qui va se poursuivre en 2023
trois priorités pour faire court dans le
délai imparti donné un Français vision
et l'an prochain également tout d'abord
la puissance numérique de France
Télévisions alors là je voudrais faire
un petit point parce qu'on parle souvent
des audiences linéaires de l'âge des
téléspectateurs je voudrais parler du
déploiement de français vivant sur le
numérique avec des chiffres de
Médiamétrie alors nous audience linéaire
vous les connaissez c'est à peu près 30%
de part de marché pour une moyenne d'âge
qui est pondérée de la durée d'écoute de
exactement 61 ans
sur une couverture très importante de la
population puisque on couvre à peu près
91% de la population par mois je pense
qu'à nous tous là on fait 100%. c'est à
dire que tous les Français ont un
contact avec le Service Public Radio
archives à l'étranger et en France bref
passons maintenant à ce qu'on voit ce
qui se passe sur notre nos plateformes
propriétaires donc vous savez que là on
a énormément simplifié l'offre on s'est
recentré sur deux grands axes tout
d'abord France Info qui est une offre
commune à nous tous qui est la
plateforme d'info qui est le premier
site d'actualité en France
qui a une couverture de 37% des Français
qui s'y rendent chaque mois et la
moyenne d'âge est de 45 ans
france.tv maintenant notre plateforme de
contenu là
tout contenu mais en particulier fiction
cinéma culture notamment qui est la
première plateforme vidéo de France qui
est de passer première en juillet et en
août devant TF1 devant M6
et qui progresse énormément en plus 30%
en un an en quatre ans nous audions sont
doublés et nous atteignons aujourd'hui
27 millions de visiteurs uniques par
mois
France Info c'est 22 millions de
visiteurs uniques par mois ce qui veut
dire que France Info un taux de
couverture de plus de 40% de la
population entre nous c'est plus que
Netflix la moyenne d'âge est aussi de 45
ans et petite information 25% des
contenus des 170 millions de vidéos vues
par mois sur cet environnement
propriétaire je parlerai ensuite des
réseaux sociaux sont des contenus
jeunesse 25%
. sur les réseaux sociaux en fin parce
que c'est notre troisième pilier
finalement on fabrique des contenus pour
nos antennes linéaires pour nos offres
numériques et pour les réseaux sociaux
c'est plus dur à compter parce qu'une
vidéo sur les réseaux sociaux n'a pas
tout à fait la même valeur qu'un
documentaire de 90 minutes sur france.tv
mais néanmoins on essaie de prendre des
chiffres qui ont un peu de sens donc
j'ai compté le nombre d'amendements
c'est-à-dire que vous êtes je ne sais
pas moi sur sur Facebook et vous avez la
démarche en tant qu'utilisateur de
Facebook de vous abonner à une offre et
à une proposition de france.tv nous
avons 11 millions d'abonnements dont je
donne ces chiffres parce qu'ils sont
intéressants 3,7 millions sur France TV
slash qui est l'offre destinée aux
jeunes adultes entre 18 et 35 ans donc
ces 3,7 millions sur un total de la
population là de ces jeunes adultes à
peu près 10 millions en France
et 5 millions sur sur France Info
d'abonnés qui délibérément sur les
réseaux sociaux uniquement on dit je
veux recevoir le fil d'infos de France
de France Info alors bien sûr c'est une
percée assez très importante
on souhaite aller évidemment un cran
plus loin et notre objectif est de
doubler la couverture du numérique c'est
d'adire d'avoir de toucher autant de
monde avec le numérique avec les chaînes
traditionnelles sur le linéaire quand je
dis numérique là c'est nos plateformes
propriétaires parce que les réseaux
sociaux c'est une autre manière
évidemment de compter même si c'est très
important
notre deuxième priorité c'est la
création et la culture et son accès à
tous
c'est une priorité d'autant plus
importante en ce moment qu'on voit que
les dépenses de culture font partie des
premiers postes qui sont supprimés par
les Français quand ils sont en
difficulté financière ce qui est le cas
on le sait aujourd'hui alors Culturebox
en 2020 à l'occasion de du confinement à
vraiment fait en 2021 nous a fait faire
un très grand bon en avant
c'est aujourd'hui la plus grande salle
de spectacles de France chaque semaine
on a 8 millions de Français qui sont au
contact d'une pièce de théâtre d'un
concert ou d'un opéra sur la chaîne
alors on va poursuivre le développement
de cet ovni audiovisuel car il joue pour
nous un rôle assez central d'accès
universel à la culture
sur tous les territoires ce qui est
aussi un enjeu très important pour cet
objectif pour la culture il se traduit
aussi par nos investissements en
création audiovisuelle et
mathémographique qui sont à hauteur de
500 millions d'euros par an
et qui sont donc un très haut niveau qui
ont fortement progressé ces dernières
années malgré je le répète ici les
effets de l'inflation sur nos comptes
troisième priorité qu'on a en partage
avec Radio France c'est notre place sur
les territoires donc c'est évidemment
une marque de fabrique de nos deux
maisons et du service public en général
pour affronter les vision c'est 50 plus
de 50% de nos effectifs qui sont qui
sont hors Paris quand on compte les
régions et les neuf territoires et
département vraiment ultramarin alors je
ne reviendrai pas sur l'outre-mer bien
que ça soit très important je centrerai
mon propos sur ce que nous faisons
ensemble avec Radio France et Sybille
sur l'offre de proximité en région donc
les matinales communes avec France Bleu
qui se continue la dernière a été
ouverte hier
la multiplication des décrochages sur
France 3 c'est-à-dire des programmes
spécifiquement régionaux culturels ou
sportifs d'ailleurs pour couvrir ces
événements ils ont été multipliés par
quatre en deux ans et puis en 2023 donc
on va marquer une très très grande étape
assez lourde à organiser chez nous
puisqu'on a décidé de mettre en place un
projet qui s'appelle tempo et qui vise à
compter de septembre 2023 à rendre les
éditions du 12-13 et du 19 20 de France
3 intégralement lancé un carnet depuis
nos 24 antennes régionales pour des
éditions complètes d'informations
ces futurs éditions seront baptisés ici
ici midi et ici soir pour donner de la
force à notre offre commune sur le
numérique et donner beaucoup de force
parce qu'on sait à quel point les
antennes sont des relais extrêmement
puissants
l'offre de proximité c'est une attente
très très forte des Français vis-à-vis
du service public et ce projet va nous
permettre de déparisé parce que c'est
comme ça que les gens nous le disent
notre offre d'information de déplacer le
centre et la focale sur l'ensemble des
territoires je rappelle que sur les
territoires ultramarins c'est déjà le
cas on a des chaînes qui sont totalement
ancrées dans leur territoire
nous avons aussi donc évidemment en
perspective un projet d'élargissement et
de puissance du service public vous
savez comme vous l'avez rappelé monsieur
le Président ce projet d'avenant est une
continuité du plan stratégique précédent
décidé en 2018 et il va nous appartenir
avec avec vous tous discuter de la suite
en tout cas à notre place certes mais de
la suite pour l'audiovisuel public moi
je voudrais puisqu'on est là encore au
très préliminaire prendre un peu ma
casquette présidente des télévisions et
radio public européenne pour vous dire
un peu ce qu'on peut observer en Europe
parce que entre nous évidemment on parle
beaucoup entre patrons des services
publics on parle beaucoup de ce qui se
passe dans nos différentes géographies
donc en gros il y a à peu près trois
solutions pour nous le premier scénario
c'est un scénario de rétrécissement donc
c'est typiquement ce qui s'est passé en
Espagne où l'opérateur public a subi des
coupes budgétaires franche en gros 25%
de coupe budgétaire qui ont entraîné 50%
de baisse d'audience
donc ils ont payé cash et en gros veut
dire que la télé est publique est
espagnole passe plus très très lourd
dans le paysage médiatique en Espagne un
autre exemple de ça c'est l'exemple
américain où il a été demandé à
l'opérature publique PIBS de se
ressenter sur ses missions de niche de
service public
pour laisser la place aux sociétés
commerciales c'est l'ultra libéralisme
américain bon aujourd'hui il y a pas de
service public on peut pas dire qu'il y
a de service public en aux États-Unis
d'où d'ailleurs les problématiques qui
se déploient avec des médias d'opinion
qui s'affrontent et la polarisation
extrême de ce pays qu'on connaît bien
deuxième scénario c'est le satu quo
c'est à dire en gros le modèle français
s'il est resté en l'état
je vous le rappelle nous avons réalisé
des efforts très importants pour foncer
vision c'est à peu près 20% d'efforts de
protéines activités et je ne suis pas la
seule à le dire l'inspection générale
des finances l'a écrit textuellement
dans son rapport et nous avons beaucoup
réduit les effectifs de manière assez
drastique 15% de baisse en disant c'est
quand même fort donc là pour moi ce
statu quo atteint ses limites et la
baisse des financements se heurte à des
exigences citoyennes qui sont par
ailleurs de plus en plus fortes pour se
projeter sur le numérique pour proposer
des séries qui viennent concurrencer les
plateformes et puis faire face aussi à
la hausse des coûts qui sont dus pour
partie pour à l'inflation et pour partie
aussi à cette concurrence extrême des
investissements des plateformes
américaines
voilà donc je pense qu'on a besoin de
retrouver de nouvelles marges de
manoeuvre alors le troisième scénario
pour moi c'est celui de l'élargissement
donc c'est intéressant de regarder qu'à
cet égard c'est le scénario allemand ou
britannique ce sont des pays qui ont
fait les choix stratégiques en fait
d'investir dans leur audiovisuel public
et je ne parle pas uniquement d'un point
de vue budgétaire je parle aussi d'un
point de vue législatif par exemple en
imposant des règles très très fortes de
visibilité des médias publics sur les
environnements connectés et l'Allemagne
et la Grande-Bretagne ont pris ces
décisions extrêmement extrêmement fortes
l'élargissement et les marges de
manoeuvre on les trouveront on les
trouvera je pense en opérant des
rapprochements stratégiques alors on y
reviendra sans doute dans les questions
rapprochement qu'on a énormément opéré
ces dernières années je pense que c'est
bien de le rappeler je sais pas s'il y a
beaucoup d'entreprises qui de leur
propre chef de leur plein gré et avec
autant de vigueur on autant construit
ensemble mais on pense et et là c'est
tous ensemble qu'on peut le dire qu'on
peut faire sans doute encore mieux au
service de nos de nos de nos concitoyens
en massifiant notamment sur le numérique
parce qu'on sait que dans un univers
ultra concurrentiel on a intérêt à être
très très solidaire les uns des autres
alors évidemment je vous cache pas que
ce scénario d'élargissement à ma
préférence
notamment parce qu'on voit que
l'information est une guerre culturelle
il est pas étonnant de voir que au fond
quand on regarde ce qui se passe en
Ukraine le président ukrainien il
s'occupe certes de ces troupes mais
aussi énormément de la formation pour
communiquer beaucoup avec mon homologue
patron de la télévision publique
ukrainienne je peux vous dire qu'il a
pas coupé les crédits de la télévision
publique ukrainienne ça c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire voilà et je pense que
nous avons besoin tous ensemble de
défendre une exception culturelle
française et une exception culturelle
européenne que nous sommes je pense les
seuls à pouvoir défendre voilà donc
j'espère que nous aurons l'occasion de
reparler de tout ça et de ce pacte de
confiance que nous devons établir avec
nos concitoyens pour notre Dieu visuel
public je vous remercie merci madame la
présidente madame veille le président de
Radio France
je pensais que c'était
alors je vais recommencer très
brièvement
mais je pensais que c'était
déjà automatique voilà
je suis à l'antenne merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
suis très heureuse d'être avec vous
aujourd'hui pour l'examen de cette
avenant un comme qui a permis à Radio
France de porter des ambitions
importantes de de nature la première la
transformation de notre média d'un média
radio en un média audio et la deuxième
la profondissement de coopération très
importante autour de nos missions de
service public avec les différents
acteurs qui sont à mes côtés aujourd'hui
sur le premier point vous le savez Radio
France est devenu ces dernières années
le premier groupe de radio en France
avec la première chaîne de radio France
France Inter France Info est devenu la
troisième radio de France mais Radio
France c'est aussi une plateforme audio
gratuite qui séduit chaque jour 10
millions de visiteurs dans 10 millions
de visiteurs uniques ce qui nous a
permis de passer il y a un an devant
Apple podcast
c'est 22 millions de Français qui sont
abonnés à nos plateformes et la somme
des auditeurs et des visiteurs uniques
sur nos sites et applications s'élèvent
chaque jour donc en couverture
quotidienne entre 20 et 21 millions de
personnes
Delphine l'a rappelé les médias qu'on
appelle souvent médias historiques ou
traditionnels gardent une puissance
quand on cumule l'eurodiance en direct
et l'audience démultipliée par leur
présence numérique qui est sans
équivalente c'est quand on regarde notre
couverture quotidienne on est devant
WhatsApp on est devant YouTube on est
devant Instagram on est devant un
Twitter et chaque mois c'est 73% de la
population que nous couvrons avec nos
contenus
on a vu combien ces dernières années le
succès des stratégies numériques à
accompagner le succès de l'écoute en
direct de nos radios il y a une prime
vraiment pour les acteurs qui ont pris
le virage numérique et que ce soit
France Info qui rayonne grâce à la
stratégie numérique portée en commun
avec les voilà l'ensemble de nos
partenaires que ce soit France Inter et
France Culture qui sont les deux leaders
du podcast en France et qui sont aussi
les radios qui ont vu moi après moi
leurs audiences augmentées encore
récemment puisqu'on a une résultat
d'audience mi-novembre pour le début de
la saison radiophonique et France Inter
et France Culture sont parmi les rares
radios qui ont vu leur nombre
d'auditeurs encore s'accroître en se
débute saison aujourd'hui Radio France
va bien aujourd'hui Radio France un prix
à certains temps d'avance sur le
numérique et vous savez comment que cela
n'avait rien d'évident il y a quelques
années encore c'est lié au pari que nous
avons fait sur le développement de
l'audio
et le boom des podcasts tout comme
l'apparition d'acteurs mondiaux du
streaming je pense Amazon Music a
Spotify et Apple podcast et bien
d'autres on montrait combien cette
stratégie était valide et on n'est pas
mal placé puisque aujourd'hui on
représente en France 50% de l'écoute des
podcasts chaque mois c'est 2 millions
d'écoute qui sont faites sur de nos
contenus soit près de 2,5 milliards par
an cette offre nouvelle que nous avons
développée grâce au podcast nous a
permis de toucher des publics jeunes et
notamment les enfants pour lesquels on a
développé tout un univers audio fait de
collection de podcasts qui n'existait
absolument pas il y a quelques années
également ces dernières années après
avoir regardé ce qui est réussissait
dans les autres pays on a rassemblé
l'ensemble des contenus produits par nos
radio dans une plateforme unique que
j'ai cité donc Radio France qui offre
une plongée unique en France dans les
savoirs l'actualité le monde des idées
de la culture des dix dernières années
et qui grâce aux partenariat avec Lina
nous permet d'aller chercher les pépites
historiques qui ont fait les grandes
heures de nos radios on y accueille
aussi les contenus de tous nos
partenaires ici présents et également
d'Arte qui n'est pas là et les podcasts
qui sont
issus des contenus faits par français
télévision
RFI ou ce qu'on fabrique avec Lina ont
de jolis succès et fond de notre
plateforme une vitrine des contenus
audio du service public
pour améliorer l'expérience du public on
a développé également un algorithme de
service public qui favorise la
découverte plutôt que bulles
d'enfermement qu'on peut trouver par
ailleurs dans d'autres plateformes je ma
faisons ce qu'on est en train de
construire et ce qu'on voit émerger
c'est qu'on est en train de construire
un poste de radio du futur et plus
précisément un poste audio qui ne se
définit plus par son support mais par la
nature des contenus qu'on écoute que ce
soit sur son téléphone portable dans sa
voiture et qu'on peut écouter et
réécouter dans la durée et ça c'est un
changement qui est majeur parce que
c'est une prime au contenu de qualité et
donc à la qualité éditoriale à quelle la
qualité technique et sonore qui est la
tradition des équipes de Radio France
parallèlement on a fait un travail
également considérable sur la
distribution pour retrouver l'autonomie
et l'indépendance de notre distribution
l'an dernier une loi a changé le Code de
la propriété intellectuelle nous
facilitons les négociations qu'on avait
avec de grandes plateformes de grands
acteurs que ce soit Amazon Spotify
Deezer qui nous ont permis de mettre
dans ses accords le respect d'une
chronologie des contenus audio que nous
avons défini nous-mêmes et des règles du
jeu plus respectueuses de la valeur des
contenus audio notamment des droits des
créateurs des droits des auteurs et on
sait combien là ces sujets sont
importants pour qui est la création
originale qui soit en France et il y a
encore un chemin à faire sur lequel
l'échappeur pourrait nous aider pour
favoriser la reconnaissance des droits
de ces auteurs
le contexte et vous le savez pour les
médias nationaux et rendus beaucoup plus
difficile par la présence d'acteurs de
globaux de grandes plateformes qui sont
très présentes dans le quotidien des
Français mais j'ai la conviction que
nous services publics nous avons chacun
d'entre nous un rôle à jouer pour aider
notre secteur face à cette
transformation notre écosystème on doit
être une locomotive on doit lancer des
innovations et c'est vraiment ce qu'on
s'est efforcé de faire ces dernières
années en développant l'innovation dans
les formats en développant une
chronologie de l'audio en travaillant
sur une technique nouvelle de soin
immersifs sur lesquels on sera laquelle
nous sommes pionniers en France en
soutenant aussi le développement du DAB+
avec les autres acteurs de la radio et
évidemment aux côtés de la com
le comme porte ensuite sur tout un
ensemble de missions de services publics
essentiels que nous accomplissons avec
nos partenaires ici présents avec
l'objectif de donner un égal accès à
tous les Français sur l'information sur
la culture et c'est pour nous un enjeu
qui est majeur un enjeu de légitimité
aussi notre existence on voit depuis
plusieurs années que se développe une
société du défouloir sur les réseaux
sociaux qui envahit certains médias et
qui finissent par inquiéter toute une
partie de la population et ce qu'on voit
dans toutes les enquêtes qui sont faites
c'est que nos médias respectifs sont
globalement préservés de la défiance
croissante des Français à l'égard des
médias et que l'utilité d'une ligne
éditoriale de service public est
clairement perçue par les citoyens et je
pense que c'est vraiment ce que nous
partageons ici avec France Télévisions
avec France media monde avec Lina avec
aussi Arte et qui donne tout ce sens aux
coopérations majeures que nous avons
développé sur les années du COM 2020
2022 des années qui ont été en matière
de coopération puisque nous avons
renforcé France Info nous avons créé
culture prime on s'est associé à l'uni
aux côtés de France Télévisions et Lina
on a mené de grandes consultations nos
médias public auprès des citoyens avec
Arte on a développé un espace concert on
a organisé pour les jeunes des
opérations qu'on appelle et maintenant
avec France Télévisions très bien
rappelé on développe des coopérations
entre France Bleu et France 3 on crée
des événements culturels forts en commun
on l'a fait à des occasions diverses sur
le Liban un concert sur l'Ukraine on a
beaucoup de coopérations culturelle
encore le week-end dernier il y avait un
Radio France un opéra de Gilberto Gilles
à molassoul qui était produit à Radio
France avec France Télévisions voilà il
y a énormément de choses que nous
faisons ensemble et ce qu'il faut voir
c'est que ces offres nouvelle que nous
avons créé
seul aucun d'entre nous n'aurait pu les
faire de la même manière il y a aussi
des synergies que nous faisons qui sont
différentes et qui elle vise à réduire
les charges respectives que nous portons
sur les achats sur la cybersécurité sur
la technique voilà il y a tout un
ensemble de coopérations que nous
portons construire les succès de ses
coopérations-là développer dans la durée
la notoriété d'offres nouvelles de
marques nouvelle ça prend du temps et la
prolongation en 2023 de ce com va nous
permettre d'amplifier fortement ces
coopérations de consolider leur succès
auprès des Français et parmi ces offres
une à une tout particulièrement qui va
continuer de s'intensifier c'est la
coopération entre France Bleu et France
3 ce sont beaucoup de chantiers que nous
avons menés dans le cadre de ce com qui
ont été fait en même temps que nous
étions engagés dans une trajectoire
d'économie importante puisque c'est 60
millions d'euros d'économies que nous
avons fait entre 2019 et 2022 cela
représente 10% de notre budget c'est un
effort considérable qui nécessitait un
plan de 340 départs sous forme de RCC
donc de rupture conventionnelle
collective et quelques 57
réorganisations au sein de Radio France
voilà ce sont des réorganisations qui
demandent la beaucoup d'efforts pour
l'ensemble des équipes l'ensemble des
salariés et j'en profite pour leur
rendre hommage puisque c'est un travail
intense qui est fait tout en développant
le média radio merci monsieur le
Président merci madame la Présidente
Marie-Christine Saragosse présidente de
France mega monde
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs en écoutant mes
collègues je me disais je pense qu'on va
le faire que si on consolidé les
chiffres qu'a donné Delphine les
chiffres que viennent de donner civils
et ceux que je m'apprête à vous donner
probablement alors Lina peut-être un peu
dans un cas différent mais Arte à
certainement des choses à ajouter aussi
je crois qu'on ferait vraiment honneur à
notre pays en termes de puissance du
service public surtout si on le rapporte
à son coût qui doit être le 14e au
niveau européen donc je alors je change
de je change d'horizon puisque je on
passe du National au fracas du monde qui
nous entoure du terrorisme au coup des
temps en cascade à la guerre en Ukraine
et j'ajoute le réchauffement climatique
est un enjeu mondial majeur qui nous
préoccupe de plus en plus et qui
préoccupe de plus en plus les jeunes
et dans cette cacophonie j'ai envie de
dire mondiale nos médias internationaux
français de services publics sont en
première ligne et affrontent d'abord une
concurrence exacerbée avec des
concurrents qui ont des moyens
les plus pauvres d'entre eux ont au
moins 100 millions d'euros de plus que
nous je vous assainerai pas tous les
autres chiffres mais je les ai je les
connais malheureusement par cœur
évidemment des tensions internationales
la fermeture de RT en Europe
immédiatement entraîné en contrepartie
la suspension des médias internationaux
en Russie mais de nous aussi au Mali
puisque RT était agité et récemment
Burkina Faso où on a eu droit aussi à RT
au Burkina Faso c'est la signature
Wagner semble-t-il
donc un contexte sécuritaire pour nos
journalistes très dégradés avec des
menaces sur le terrain mais aussi des
cyberattaques d'une raviolence dont nous
ne parlons pas trop parce que lentilles
nous le demande et puis et puis beaucoup
de messages à caractère haineux que nos
journalistes dans leur 20 langues
reçoivent d'un peu partout dans le monde
voilà mais donc je vais me permettre de
vous citer monsieur le rapporteur
je crois qu'on peut dire comme vous
l'avez écrit que rarement la nécessité
pour la France de disposer d'un
opérateur audiovisuel de taille mondial
n'aura paru aussi nécessaire
alors en dépit de ce contexte ou
peut-être à cause de ce contexte
d'ailleurs nos résultats n'ont jamais
été aussi élevés alors bien sûr il y a
ceux qui figurent dans l'exécution du
COM et c'est 2021 comme on est presque à
la fin 2022 je vais me permettre de
donner les derniers chiffres
[Musique]
3,100 milliards de vidéos et de son
lancer sur le numérique en 2022 fin
novembre avec une durée moyenne de
consommation de 5 minutes ce qui n'est
pas totalement négligeable
4 millions de podcasts consommés par
mois 100 millions d'abonnés sur Facebook
Twitter YouTube et Instagram
fRANCE 24 est ainsi le premier média
français sur Facebook et Youtube avec
sur le sol YouTube 2,5 milliards de
contenu consommé
donc ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est
que quand on tente des expérimentations
comme on l'a fait d'ailleurs avec nos
collègues sur culture prime sur TiK ToK
on a 1,5 millions de j'aime sur Tik Tok
en l'espace d'une seule une seule
tentative ce qu'on a commencé avec une
job prime surinter qui est l'offre de
France médiamonde pour les jeunes
Européens et qui qui compte 85% de 18 34
ans
une seule vidéo la première qu'on a
lancé pour tester 600 000 vues
donc en fait on est je crois qu'on est
très présent sur les réseaux sociaux
pour autant je veux dire le broadcast
domine encore il y a beaucoup de pays et
je crois qu'il faut pas opposer une
chose à l'autre et si on est très connu
sur le numérique c'est aussi parce qu'on
est plus sombre de casque c'est
important d'être sur le numérique et sur
les réseaux sociaux en particulier
un double titre parce que c'est là que
je joue la lutte contre les infox c'est
évidemment là c'est pas en restant sur
nos sites propriétaires qu'on va réussir
à contrecarrer les manipulations de
l'info donc il faut y aller en quelque
sorte et puis aussi c'est parce que
c'est le signe que y compris les jeunes
attendent vu le succès qu'on a tous ils
attendent des choses de qualité et
s'agissant de nous une information
professionnelle non partisane vérifiée
indépendante libre démocratique
et pas seulement en France donc ils
attendent ça partout dans le monde donc
c'est d'ailleurs ça tombe bien parce que
c'est le premier objectif de notre com
et de son avenant délivrer une
information professionnelle c'est à dire
tous les adjectifs que j'ai cité qui
permet de lutter contre les infos ce qui
est un premier rang aux infos et on le
fait en 20 langues en plus du français
le deuxième objectif qui était celui du
commissaire et qui est aussi dans
l'avenant et je voudrais quand même dire
que on n'est pas en statu quo on fait
pas des on ne fait pas du sur place avec
je sais bien que c'est peut-être pas
assez ambitieux mais on bosse tellement
que ça on n'est pas du tout immobile
parce que c'est un avenant on a des
objectifs très ambitieux et on continue
donc le deuxième objectif qui est
assigné à France média monde je vais le
résumer aussi sous le terme proximité
alors c'est pas France Bleu France 3
mais c'est ce délocaliser et utiliser la
langue de nos auditeurs notamment des
langues africaines qui ont un fort
succès donc on a lancé également là on
vient de lancer une offre 100% en
ukrainien
mais renforcer notre offre en russe
depuis Bucarest nous avons une radio RFI
Romania et nous avons donc créé une
rédaction avec des journalistes
Ukrainiens russophone et ucret et
ukrainophones avec des premiers
résultats ça fait un mois 100000 visites
sans encore de communication
on a développé en Afrique à Dakar une
offre destinée à la bande sahélienne en
full fulder c'est le pull la langue des
peuples et le mandingan très fort succès
et puis France 24 en espagnol un budget
constant a réussi l'exploit grâce à
[Musique]
le site d'éducation du service public
qui est piloté par France Télévisions et
Lina on fait un travail essentiel
d'éducation aux médias à l'information
parce que c'est grâce à ça que on sera
protégé des infos que si on s'éduquant
aussi soi-même et vraiment je voudrais
saluer cette action aussi qui est une
vraiment une action de service public
quatrième objectif notre gestion nous
serons en équilibre en 2022 après avoir
été avec des résultats excédentaires
dans les deux dernières années donc nous
suivons scrupuleusement notre
trajectoire nous suivons aussi
scrupuleusement les recommandations de
la Cour des comptes et notamment aussi
en matière de RSE et d'urgence
climatique qui est un grand chantier
interne et également un chantier sur nos
antennes
nos objectifs communs on en a parlé j'en
ai parlé d'ailleurs France Info
évidemment que ça ça fonctionne très
bien et que on est tout à fait on est
tous dans la vie l'envie d'aller plus
loin lui vient d'en parler culture prime
je vous ai dit le succès qu'on avait vu
sur TikTok et ça va continuer je crois
qu'on fait beaucoup de choses
importantes qu'on ne valorise pas assez
on n'est pas assez des marketeurs de ce
qu'on fait c'est dommage on doit se
vendre plus parce qu'on fait franchement
beaucoup de choses il y a des
coopérations qui ne se voient pas si
Bill y a fait allusion sur les
cyberattaques on est totalement en phase
sur sur la recherche et le développement
moi je voudrais saluer ce qu'on a pu
faire avec France Télévisions et avec
Radio France son français vision on ne
pourrait pas avec l'intelligence
artificielle sous-titrée toutes les
vidéos de France 24 en ukrainien c'est
avec France Télévisions qu'on a
développé ça avec Radio France on
développe le disons la circulation dans
les podcasts comment comment
utiliser au mieux les podcasts comment
s'y retrouver comme tout ça c'est avec
Radio France évidemment qu'on peut le
faire donc sur la recherche et le
développement la force du service public
et sa mobilisation
mutualisée est essentiel pour l'avenir
et je pense qu'en recherche et
développement plus Lina qui fait un gros
raout demain j'ai vu ça je crois Laurent
a beaucoup d'outils de recherche pour
préparer l'avenir aussi donc là on a une
grande force tous ensemble
alors la suite donc on va y travailler
ce sera le prochain comme je dis je
conclue avec un enjeu les enjeux de
financement 2023 ça pour nous ça passe
ça passe pas large mais ça passe par
rapport aux autres années où il a fallu
faire des économies drastiques mais
l'enjeu il est pour le futur il est
double la nature du financement et sa
trajectoire à l'international la nature
du financement n'est pas une simple
posture la nature du financement des
conséquences immédiates sur le
rapporteur vous le savez à Berlin
nos amis allemands nous ont fait savoir
qu'une budgétisation c'était un flirt
beaucoup trop étroit avec l'État et que
ça n'était pas conforme à la législation
allemande donc on est avec une épée de
Damoclès sur notre tête on ne sait pas
si on ne va pas perdre notre fréquence
FM à Berlin qu'on a depuis 24 ans parce
que nous serions budgétisé
c'est quand même très embêtant sur les
réseaux sociaux il faut savoir que
ruchatoudet avait demandé que France 24
soit qualifié de chaîne gouvernementale
parce que c'était une chaîne publique et
non justement YouTube a répondu mais non
ils sont ils ont un faisceau d'indices
d'indépendance la nomination du
président les modalités de financement
la loi etc si on fait sauter un
financement affecté
on est dans le même statut cruche à tout
des je me dis franchement donc il y a
pas de raison qu'on soit pas chez le
gouvernementale aussi et pour lutter
contre les infoges franchement il y a
mieux quelle chaîne gouvernementale donc
faut-il faire une charte républicaine je
c'est une idée que j'ai mise
je pense qu'il faut une charte
républicaine de l'indépendance comme la
BBC en a une pour garantir à
l'international notre indépendance c'est
important mais les modalités de
financement aussi et la non
budgétisation
ce serait important même en principe en
position de principe parce que la FM va
être attribuée là elle va pas attendre
que on ait fini notre discussion donc
moi je demande au Parlement de nous
donner une position de principe pour
dire qu'on gardera une recette affectée
quelle que soit sa forme et après il y a
le la trajectoire et je cette
trajectoire je sais qu'elle sera
contrainte c'est pourquoi je redis ici
que puisque nos dépenses à France
médiumonde
sont calculés dans l'aide publique au
développement français à hauteur de 20
millions c'est-à-dire 20 millions de ce
qu'on fait et repris dans le calcul de
l'aide publique française de
développement je dis juste et bien
mettons les recettes qui vont en face de
ces dépenses en aide publique au
développement ça allégera le reste du
secteur et ça nous permettra de nous de
continuer à ne pas décrocher face à la
concurrence internationale alors même
qu'il s'agit à travers de l'ensemble de
nos actions de favoriser la Liberté
d'informer qui est un bien précieux qui
est le fondement de la démocratie qui
est malmené à l'échelle du monde
et c'est là une mission essentielle de
médias de services publics
internationaux français voilà je vous
remercie merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur lanvallet président de l'INA
président monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs
je vais essayer d'être bref
en effet tout au long de ces de son
dernier contrat d'objectif et le moyen
dans un mouvement qui avait été initié
donc précédent poursuivi sa
transformation qu'on peut résumer en
disant qu'au fond c'est ce qui est au
cœur du comme ça qui est donc de son
avenant qui le proje pour 2023 c'est
c'est l'affirmation de son statut de
média ça transformation en média vous
savez toutes et tous Lina
c'est du fait de l'histoire l'héritage
d'un certain nombre d'activités un peu
épars de l'exert voilà c'était ce qui ne
contribuait pas tuer à clarté de son
identité c'était à la fois un centre
d'archivage un centre de formation un
centre de production un centre de
recherche aujourd'hui c'est un média un
média patrimonial de service public
distinctif qui qui apporte sa différence
et de la différence
au service public de baudiovisuel ce qui
est je crois que quelque chose
d'important pour assurer durablement sa
légitimité et ce média de service public
ce média patrimonial il y a évidemment
nourri de toutes les activités de Lina
non seulement les activités éditoriales
les plus visibles celle que vous
connaissez sans doute à travers ce qu'on
poste sur nos sites nos réseaux sociaux
mais aussi j'insiste sans ni attarder
trop mais nos activités de recherche
puisque en effet en venant plugger si je
puis dire nos solutions d'intelligence
artificielle développée par nos
chercheurs dans des dans de certains
projets qui sont d'ailleurs labellisés à
NR puisque la recherche de Linas c'est
c'est aussi un héritage du passé mais
avec un département qui occupe une
quinzaine de chercheurs en employant nos
solutions et les solutions de
d'intelligence artificielle développée
récemment sur l'immense ressource du
dépôt vegan audiovisuel on peut produire
des des on peut produire de la de la
data de l'analyse de l'analyse
médiatique par exemple
étudiants depuis deux ou trois ans aux
études que publie chaque année l'arcom
sur les représentations de genre et
représentations des femmes dans sur les
écrans et en venant ajouter aux données
déclaratives des chaînes des mesures de
temps de parole grâce à cette solution
d'intelligence artificielle d'un de nos
chercheurs qui reconnaît à coup sûr
c'est un homme ou une femme qui parle
voilà donc ce média distinctif
patrimonial et nourri par bien sûr je
vais y revenir dans un instant les
activités éditoriales de publication de
contenu du visuel mais aussi j'insiste
par la recherche mais aussi par nos
activités de transmission des savoirs
qui se sont aussi
transformés ces dernières années
notamment à travers
le déploiement au sein de notre peau
inassume de formation initiale de notre
classe alpha
une initiative inclusive qui permet
d'intégrer des jeunes sans pré-requis de
diplôme et de les remettre dans un
cursus professionnelisant ou prêt
professionnel
on est désormais soutenu par France
Télévisions on sera bientôt par Radio
France où on commence à être en termes
de notamment d'accueil d'accueil de
stagiaires d'alternance et c'est très
précieux c'est un très bel exemple même
si le financement n'est pas pour
l'instant pas assuré dans la durée
puisque l'essentiel outre les
investissements de Lina était financé
par dans le cadre du Programme régional
va justement dans les compétences de la
région Île-de-France
sur un plan éditorial donc Lina c'est
considérablement transformé dans sa
politique éditoriale et et avec cette
cette ligne qui consiste à ancrer ses
publics dans le temps long dans une
démarche d'analyse et de décryptage de
l'info et de l'actualité avec des
archives qui je crois a connu un certain
succès au plan éditorial
je suis arrivé
à peu près 70 ou 80 millions de vidéos
vues on sera un milliard 3 cette année
ce que faisait Arte en 2019 mais nous on
a commencé qu'il y a cinq ou six ans
voilà donc je crois que là aussi et
comme on dit mes collègues je veux
absolument contrebattre l'idée que qui
traîne pas conduit parfois ici ou là que
nous serions un peu un peu des nains
numériques
on n'est pas que Lina aujourd'hui 10
millions d'abonnés
à ces offres gratuites ces pages de
réseaux sociaux ces plateformes vidéo
c'est plus c'est plus que d'abonnés que
brut en France on a 50000 abonnés à
notre offre de vidéo par abonnement à la
demande Madeleine 50 000 abonnés payants
c'est plus que
c'est plus d'abonnés que les abonnés
numériques aux parisiens ou à Télérama
là aussi en deux ans pour une offre
culturelle qui rassemble des programmes
audiovisuels de patrimoine et aussi un
certain nombre de programme frais à qui
à travers des acquisitions de catalogues
tout le tout très fortement éditorialisé
bon je vais pas je vais pas vous
assainer trop de chiffres bon d'ailleurs
au passage malienne c'est un regret de
croissance pour notre chiffre d'affaires
parce que vous savez Lina et le seuil
des organismes de public qui doit
assurer à lui seul enfin qui doit
assurer à peu près 35% de ses revenus
par du chiffre d'affaires
autre que de la de la redevance comme on
disait naillère
et de ce point de vue là aussi le job a
été fait on a maintenu et même un peu
augmenté ton anciennement cette part
on est on n'a pas encore les chiffres
définitifs pour 2022 mais voilà je crois
que cette dynamique qu'on a enclenché
elle devrait permettre de d'accroître le
chiffre d'affaires en 2022 on devrait
être je compare évidemment pas à 2020
qui était
un creux historique pour des raisons
bien bien par rapport à 2019 on devrait
progresser de près de 6 millions d'euros
plus 23% de chiffre d'affaires ça tombe
bien parce que compte tenu de la
dotation budgétaire qui nous a été
alloué par le périph de 1023 il va
falloir encore compter beaucoup sur nos
propres forces voilà donc on espère que
on continuera cette dynamique mais je
suis confiant avec parieur était portée
par une forte transformation interne
dans l'entreprise
un effort de productivité important
échec de Lina puisque sur environ 1000
ETP enfin mille pardon de 1000 emplois
on en a on a sur la depuis 6 ans on a on
a diminué il y a 60
60 TP en moins c'est la logique de des
com qui plafonnaient non pas les
effectifs mais
mais la masse salariale ce qui revient
un peu au même quand on a parlé en
accord d'entreprise qui a croit
mécaniquement chaque année les
rémunérations les rémunération
individuelle
donc on s'est transformé dans notre
organisation interne on a créé il y a un
an et demi une grande direction
data et technologique qui est beaucoup
mieux adapté aujourd'hui à ce qui est
devenue Lina après après cette phase
qu'il a occupé presque 25 ans de
numérisation
de l'ensemble du patrimoine
radiophonique et télévisé français ce
qui fait des d'ailleurs au passage là
aussi c'est une autre illustration du
fait qu'on est loin d'être le deuxième
pique français
non seulement chacune des entreprises
pris séparément et a fortiori l'ensemble
loin d'être des nains puisque linase
avec 26 millions d'heures de vidéos
intégralement numérisées indexées et le
premier
centre de première librairie si je puis
dire de vidéos numérisées indexées en
Europe et sans doute au monde il y a une
petite controverse avec la librairie du
du Congrès à Washington mais on n'arrive
pas à avoir les vrais chiffres donc
peut-être on est que numéro 2 au monde
en tout cas là aussi c'est c'est la
preuve que sur le numérique on existe de
plein de façons voilà donc
aujourd'hui on a fait tout ça en
accroissant y compris ces derniers mois
des coopérations avec
avec nos nos collègues et nos nos
partenaires de DJ public je dois dire
que chacun des partenaires des
partenariats qu'on a été amenés à nouer
ont été pour wina en tant que tel aussi
un accélérateur de sa propre
transformation et le fait que on est on
était embarqué dès le début dans
l'aventure France Info
évidemment ça a été un moteur très
puissant pour pour être en formation de
de la politique éditoriale de Lina et
son ancrage autour de l'actu plutôt que
de la nostalgie ou de la rétroactualité
comment on disait à l'époque grâce à
France Télévisions on copiloté la
refonte de l'offre éducative du service
public nourri par l'ensemble des
partenaires mais avec deux éditeurs inaf
s'occupant de la partie dite
professionnelle ça existe destiné plus
spécifiquement aux professeurs aux
élèves en sac de classe qui pouvaient
être accessibles par feu et du Tech je
dis feu et du Tech parce que face au
succès de l'uni enseignement qui est la
partie donc dite professionnelle à côté
de l'uni grand public édite France
Télévisions mais qui sont évidemment
étroitement imbriqués et du Tech et le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale nous
a annoncé il y a nous proposer à neuf
mois de nous confier en réalité du Tech
et ses ressources et du Tech a été
dissout si je puis dire dans le menu
enseignement mais dissous avec
avec le consentement de toutes les
parties concernées un nouveau humide
enseignement qui je crois donne toute
satisfaction mystère de l'éducation
nationale et dont les chiffres de
fréquentation par des professeurs ize
sont extrêmement satisfaisants a vu le
jour mi-septembre ça aussi c'est le
fruit donc d'un travail collaboratif
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure France
Télévisions a apporté son soutien depuis
presque deux ans maintenant à notre
classe alpha à travers l'accueil de
de l'accueil de stagiaires ou
d'alternance et on est en train de
commencer à le faire aussi avec nos amis
de de Radio France voilà donc en effet
avenant
sous réserve de la question des moyens
qui va devoir nous qui va nous obliger à
être à nouveau très performant dans
notre chiffre d'affaires commercial mais
disons qu'on va le prendre comme un défi
à relever
voilà il prend en effet une stratégie
qui qui je crois
permet de renforcer la singularité du
média public global par l'apport de
toute la production éditoriale mais pas
que de Lina au contenu au sens large y
compris pédagogique ou de recherche
proposé par duel public de ce pays voilà
j'ai été un peu bon je vous remercie
merci monsieur le Président on va
commencer les premières questions par
celle de notre rapporteur j'aurais beau
Gonnet
merci président
mesdames messieurs j'aurai une question
pour chacune et chacun d'entre vous je
vais commencer par madame la Présidente
de France Télévisions et cette question
portera sur salto et la stratégie
numérique que vous avez déjà un petit
peu abordé salto n'a jamais emporté la
conviction de notre commission des 2018
mon prédécesseur Jean-Pierre Leleu
exprimait dans son avis budgétaire je
cite son étonnement que le groupe public
axe sa stratégie numérique
principalement sur une offre payante
développée par des acteurs privés en
contradiction avec les fondements même
du service public de l'audiovisuel on ne
peut évidemment que regretter le
caractère prémonitoire de nos réserves
d'alors les chèques de salto pose
clairement la question de l'avenir de la
stratégie numérique de France
Télévisions et des moyens qui seront
affectés à cette ambition quel bilan
faites-vous de salto combien aura coûté
ce projet au groupe public sur la
période
2019-2023 partagez-vous aujourd'hui
notre conviction que audiovisuel public
n'est pas légitime à proposer une offre
payante qui lui revient de se distinguer
des offres privées par des programmes
différents sur des supports propres vous
avez par ailleurs vous aviez par
ailleurs évoqué dans votre projet lors
de renouvellement de votre mandat en
2020 l'idée de créer une plateforme
commune à l'audiovisuel public France
media plus est-ce que vous considérez
qu'un tel projet est toujours possible
aujourd'hui et comment le mettre en
œuvre
la Présidente je vais vous laisser
répondre à cette première question merci
donc nous n'étions pas d'accord nous ne
sommes toujours pas première remarque
salto n'est pas la stratégie numérique
de France Télévisions je crois que la
stratégie numérique de France
Télévisions et je pense avoir été assez
précis sur les résultats de celle-ci
dans mon propos liminaire c'est la
concentration autour de deux plateformes
mères que sont France Info pour
l'information et France TV pour les
contenus je rappelle les chiffres
monsieur Hugonnet 25 millions de
visiteurs uniques sur france.tv 22
millions sur France Info
France Info est la première offre
d'informations en France et un peu en
équest ce que disait maritime tout à
l'heure c'est vrai qu'on a l'impression
qu'on fait jamais assez c'est je le dis
souvent mais nous pour sur France Info
on a eu la visite de la BBC de la télé
suédoise de la rail ils sont tous venus
voir comment on avait fait pour ensemble
réaliser ce succès donc on peut dire que
c'est on peut faire mieux et je pense
que d'ailleurs on se dit nous-même qu'on
peut faire mieux en tout cas la
stratégie numérique de français vision
c'est celle-là salto c'est autre chose
nous avions nous avons une filiale de
production nous avons une filiale de
distribution et nous avons une filiale
de SVOD commune avec France avec TF1 et
M6 c'est une stratégie de
diversification qui n'est d'ailleurs pas
financée par par le la contribution à le
diviser le public alors est-ce que salto
on a eu tort de faire salto je rappelle
quand même que quand le projet de fusion
était sur la table et il a été longtemps
mine de rien salto était au cœur du
projet de fusion TF1 M6 donc on peut
dire d'un côté que ça n'a aucun intérêt
mais c'est quand même intéressant de
savoir que deux boîtes cotées privées
qui avait l'intention de fusionner
mettez salto au cœur de leur projet
d'ailleurs à l'époque nous avions
convenu avec eux de nous retirer de
salto puisque c'était le cœur de leur
projet commun en fait si cette fusion si
cette fusion survenait bon
cette fusion ne survient pas et là on
voit quand même nos partenaires qui qui
sont des grands fauves privés si je puis
dire ça comme ça qui ont des stratégies
un peu différentes aujourd'hui et là où
ils pensaient travailler ensemble ils se
voient plutôt agir séparément et donc là
cette solidité de cette actionnariat à 3
est un peu mise en défaut le premier à
avoir exprimé ces Rodolphe belle-mère le
nouveau patron de TF1 qui a dit je me
retire bon partons de là la messe était
dit alors j'y reviendrai sur la valeur
de salto parce que
on a beaucoup de d'intérêt qui s'est
exprimé de la part d'acteurs extrêmement
sérieux pour le rachat de salto donc on
verra je peux pas vous répondre on verra
ensuite la suite du processus mais quand
même ce que je voudrais dire c'est qu'il
y a un enseignement qui moi reste
pertinent pour moi dans salto c'est
qu'en quelques années on a réussi à
faire 800 000 abonnés payants et quand
je dis 800 000 on doit être plus ça fait
plus d'un mois et demi que je dis 800
000 donc je ne connais pas les chiffres
là mais ça encore augmenté
rien du tout il faut vous imaginer qu'on
a des gens qui sont prêts à payer pour
avoir certes la distribution qu'ils ont
déjà gratuites par ailleurs des chaînes
TF1 M6 etc etc mais pour avoir en
avant-première des contenus français
c'est ça qui est très intéressant je
trouve dans l'initiative salto c'est le
pari qu'on avait fait en fait on se
disant on investit quand même beaucoup
en création on a on a des programmes on
le voit qui attire des millions de
français tous les jours si on est
capable de leur donner parce qu'on n'a
pas les moyens de faire autrement parce
qu'on n'a pas on n'est pas propriétaire
des programmes donc on n'a pas la
possibilité de les exposer aDVITAM
eternâme sur nos plateformes sinon je
pense qu'on l'aurait fait mais on ne
peut pas en fait
et bien pour donner une deuxième vie
assez programmable les mettre en
avant-première on voit que ça ça a de la
valeur donc je pense que c'est un
enseignement à positif en fait à retirer
pour l'ensemble de la création et plus
généralement de l'audiovisuel en France
les programmes sur les chaînes de télé
privées publiques sont de bonne qualité
et il y a des gens qui sont payés sont
prêts à payer pour les voir et nombreux
voilà donc on verra je comprends tout à
fait votre question monsieur le
rapporteur je pense que à la fin de
l'histoire en contrat en contrat tout ça
et on verra comment la suite de salto va
s'écrire sans doute avec d'autres
d'autres actionnaires mais ça n'est pas
la stratégie numérique de français
vision c'est ça que je voulais sur
lequel je voulais insister
[Musique]
sur la suite
la deuxième question c'est vrai sur ah
oui franchement oui oui alors on nous
sommes en train de travailler avec avec
mes collègues on se voit quasiment deux
fois par jour en ce moment pour essayer
de d'imaginer dans les dans le les crins
qui est le nôtre c'est à dire avec ce
que nous sommes
nos
l'ensemble des salariés de nos maisons
leurs inquiétudes légitimes dans une
période quand même on rappelle qu'après
des plans d'économie assez massif on ne
sait pas ce qu'il advient ce qu'il
advient l'audiovisuel public dans un an
donc imaginez vous quand même cette
situation donc on essaie de trouver et
bien entre nous la meilleure façon de
continuer à avancer ensemble je voudrais
revenir là-dessus parce que si il a très
bien dit tout à l'heure en listant quand
même une une somme assez impressionnante
de synergies qui ne demande à chacun des
efforts qui ça demande à chacun du temps
supplémentaire alors qu'on a tous baissé
nos effectifs alors qu'on a tous de
budget et qu'on a dû tous investir sur
le numérique donc c'est un triple salto
en fait que qui a été qui nous a été
demandé ces dernières années baisser les
budgets faire plus et faire ensemble et
tout ça et bien je crois qu'on a pu le
réaliser on est assez on l'a réalisé on
est toutes et tous fiers de de faire ce
qu'on fait je crois
mais ça nous a demandé un énorme effort
est-ce qu'on est prêt à aller au-delà
bien sûr mais je pense qu'il faut qu'on
le fasse ensemble dans le respect des
uns des autres et avec la Concorde qui
est la nôtre aujourd'hui
deuxième question la deuxième question
s'adresse à madame la Présidente de
Radio France Radio France a réussi en
peu de temps à développer une véritable
stratégie numérique remarquable je ne
vous intéresse donc pas sur ce sujet
une autre de nos préoccupations
constantes concernent la coopération et
les mutuelles des actions entre les
différentes entreprises de l'audiovisuel
public les comme
2019-2022 avait insisté sur la nécessité
de les développer sur une base
volontaire aujourd'hui tout le monde
reconnaît qu'il est difficile de
poursuivre les projets communs sans
faire évoluer la gouvernance notre
commission a fait plusieurs propositions
à ce sujet le rapport le le gatolin 2015
a été le premier à proposer la création
d'une holding de l'audiovisuel public il
a même inspiré le projet de loi de
Franck Riester de 2020 plus récemment
j'ai proposé avec mon collègue Roger
caoutchi d'examiner les avantages que
pour être avoir une fusion plus récente
entre les quatre sociétés de
l'audiovisuel public national
est-ce que vous partagez aujourd'hui le
constat que les coopérations menées sur
une base volontaire ont atteint leur
limite et quel serait selon vous les
avantages et les inconvénients de la
création soit du néolding soit d'une
entreprise unique fusionnée
monsieur sénateur tout d'abord merci de
saluer les la stratégie numérique de
Radio France et de porter par ses
équipes ce que vous avez fait
dans différents avis et rapports à votre
question me donne l'occasion de rappeler
le bilan très important des coopérations
qui ont été menées ces dernières années
et comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure dans
mon propos liminaire ces coopérations
nous ont permis de faire des choses que
nous n'aurions pas pu faire chacun seul
Laurent vallée d'ailleurs a très bien
exprimé à quel point ces coopération
avait été transformées pour nous quand
on a fait France Info ça nous a obligé à
développer une compétence en images qui
nous a servi ensuite pour notre présence
numérique donc ces coopérations sont des
facteurs de transformation de nos
différentes maisons et c'est surtout
l'occasion de créer des offres nouvelles
utiles aux français qu'on n'aurait pas
pu créer seul donc avec la force de nos
convictions respectives et je pense que
ces convictions elles s'appuie sur les
valeurs qui nous le relie parce que nous
sommes tous des entreprises de services
publics donc nous partageons tous des
valeurs de services publics et ce sont
ces valeurs là qui font que quand nos
équipes travaillant ensemble elles
travaillent très bien j'ai porté soutenu
beaucoup de ses coopérations je suis
très favorable poursuite et c'est dans
cet état d'esprit là que j'aborde
d'ailleurs l'année qui vient on va
devoir négocier le futur contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens et comme
Delphine Ernotte vient de le dire nous
en discutons beaucoup et nous essayons
de voir comment de manière constructive
continuer à avancer ensemble avec le
souci de l'intérêt général et de
l'utilité pour les concitoyens
précisément sur
la question de du mode de gouvernance et
de son évolution dans l'hypothèse où
pourrait y avoir où il y aurait par
exemple un projet de texte qui n'est pas
le cas pour l'instant mais si devait y
avoir un projet une évolution
ma conviction c'est que il faut que ça
aille vers une structure qui soit agile
de manière à favoriser le partager
stratégies de manière à faciliter le
travail des équipes qui sont engagées
dans les coopérations je rappelle que
c'est pas de nous que la décision sur la
forme de la gouvernance dépend c'est le
pouvoir souverain du pouvoir exécutif et
législatif et que nous nous mettrons en
oeuvre de la manière la plus responsable
possible en emmenant nos équipes les
évolutions qui seront décidées par
le pouvoir exécutif et législatif
en 2019 quand le ministre de la Culture
franc christer avait porté le projet de
loi que vous avez rappelé de création
d'une ligne moi-même et je crois pouvoir
dire son mangager trop que mes collègues
ici présents nous avions tous soutenus
le projet porté par le gouvernement à
l'époque et ce projet avait de
caractéristiques c'est qui préservaient
la complémentarité et la spécificité de
chacun de nos médias et ses spécificités
ont été rappelés par chacun d'entre nous
je pense aujourd'hui dans les
présentations qu'on a fait de des enjeux
du COM et donner un cadre constructif
pour les coopérations et ma conviction
c'est vraiment celle-là c'est qu'il faut
préserver il faut s'appuyer et
capitaliser sur les transformations qui
sont en cours dans chacune de nos
maisons donc nos complémentarités avant
tout par exemple Radio France nous on
porte le développement de l'audio on
essaie de le faire en AM aussi
l'ensemble du secteur de la radio et
c'est cette actif là qu'on apporte à
l'utiliser le public et qu'on
apporterait qu'on doit continuer à
apporter quel que soit l'évolution de la
gouvernance
troisième question
elle sera pour madame la Présidente de
France médiamonde les concurrents de
France médiamont sur la scène
internationale dispose vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure madame la Présidente de
moyens bien plus conséquent pour rappel
396 millions d'euros pour dodgevez-le
360 millions d'euros pour BBC World
Service à comparer aux 255 millions
d'euros pour France média monde en 2021
l'augmentation du budget de France media
monde pour l'année 2023 ne permet pas
d'atteindre le niveau de ses concurrents
d'autant plus que la grande partie de
cette augmentation constitue une
croissance purement faciale avec la
compensation des faits fiscaux liés à la
suppression de la redevance comme la
rappeler le président de la commission
tout à l'heure faute de moyens
suffisants France médiumonde à
développer le recours à des financements
complémentaires avec l'Agence française
de développement avec l'Union européenne
et dernièrement avec des fonds du
ministère des Affaires étrangères pour
le lancement de la rédaction de RFI en
ukrainien
est-ce que ces financements externes ont
vocation à être pérennisé quels sont les
risques inhérents à l'absence de
prévisibilité de ces financements dans
le temps quel serait le justement temps
de ces financements annexes nécessaires
pour la période 2024 2028 compte tenu
des projets envisagés par France médias
monde dans le contexte de crise
internationale que nous connaissons
merci monsieur le rapporteur pour cette
question alors je vous remercie aussi
d'avoir rappelé les chiffres que j'ai
pas osé vous assiner tout à l'heure
parce qu'ils sont assez éloquents mais
je tiens à préciser que il concerne le
Dieu de l'extérieur mais l'audiovisuel
national puisque je pense que les
budgets nationaux pour
[Musique]
sont beaucoup plus élevés évidemment
oui en effet donc ça va forcément avec
des redevances plus importantes
alors s'agissant de l'audiovisuel
extérieur en effet vous avez relevé
monsieur le sénateur le
développement récents ont été financés
en quelque sorte sur projet avec des
sortes de CDD financiers puisque
quand on a une recette qui nous vient de
l'Union européenne ou de la FD l'Agence
française de développement ce sont des
recettes sur projet des financements sur
projet ça se passe très bien je veux
dire on travaille très bien par exemple
avec l'Agence française de développement
avec la FD mais le problème c'est que
notre temps notre temps d'action est la
durée dans laquelle on doit s'inscrire
n'est pas celle de ne sont pas ceux de
la FD dire que un temps d'instruction
très long et un projet très court c'est
à peu près le contraire de ce qu'on fait
nous on doit agir vite souvent en
réaction vite dans une situation
d'urgence et s'inscrire dans le temps
donc c'est presque une incompatibilité
de fonctionnement et pas et pas
d'intérêt ou de compréhension c'est pas
du tout des donc du coup ben fin 2023
par exemple
le financement de notre projet
aprikibaro c'est à dire le projet à
Dakar sur le mandat quand elle full
fulder s'achève il représente 3,3
millions d'euros par an sur trois ans et
demi
donc du coup mais ce serait vraiment pas
le moment d'arrêter de parler peu les
mandincants dans la bande sahélienne ce
serait franchement pas le moment il
faudrait même au contraire monter en
puissance monter en puissance sur les
réseaux sociaux éventuellement même
faire de la télévision depuis Dakar
enfin il faudrait au contraire monter en
puissance alors c'est pourquoi je je
disais puisqu'on parlait de BBC alors en
tout cas BBC les Allemands c'est vrai
aussi pour le la dot je vais le mais BBC
reçoit chaque année 85 millions de
livres sterling dette publique au
développement financer directement sans
passer par l'opérateur d'être public au
développement c'est à dire l'équivalent
de l'AFD c'est financer directement
pour la BBC World 85 millions de livres
moi je leur demande pas autant
modestement je dis juste que la France
compte dans ses dépenses d'aide publique
au développement 20 millions de nos
dépenses qui sont aujourd'hui financées
pas du tout par des publics au
développement et moi j'aimerais beaucoup
que ces 20 millions arrivent chez nous
progressivement sur le prochain comme
aller 4 x 5 donc 50 comes 4 millions par
an pour
consolider ce qu'on fait là y compris à
Bucarest développer quelque chose dans
le monde arabe parce qu'il faut il faut
il faut y aller là dans le monde arabe
aussi au plus près au plus près et
monter en puissance sur ça sur les
réseaux sociaux en direction de la
jeunesse faire un inter africain faire
un inter Africain enfin ce genre de les
projets on les a si on nous donnait 4
millions de plus par an dettes publiques
au développement en direct pour aller
vite et bien je pense que ça ferait des
vacances à nos collègues qui n'auraient
pas qui nous auraient pas sur le dos sur
le la recette collective et que ce
serait fort logique et cohérent avec ce
qui se passe dans d'autres pays
démocratiques
voilà ce que je est-ce que je sais pas
si j'ai alors Vial 209 on pourrait tout
à fait être financé directement je pense
que ça ne se verrait même pas puisqu'il
y a 15 milliards d'être publiques au
développement donc ce serait derrière
une virgule dans un jeu d'écriture non
mais voyez c'est on parle de petites
sommes qui changerait beaucoup de choses
pour nous pardon j'ai pas entendu
c'est ça qui vous a fait non je veux
dire c'est une petite somme sur étalée
sur cinq ans qui changerait la face de
notre action et qui surtout la
sécuriserait dans le temps donc je vois
ce que je
et je vous remercie pour votre question
merci dernière question oui elle
s'adressera donc à monsieur le Président
de Lina le com
2019-2022 de Lina prévoyait de faire de
la mutualisation de la formation
initiale et continue des sociétés de
l'audiovisuelle publique un chantier
prioritaire des coopérations toutefois
cet objectif figurait dans le socle
commun des différents comes davantage
sous l'angle d'une réflexion à conduire
que d'un véritable objectif opérationnel
à atteindre si cette question ne semble
pas avoir beaucoup progressé dans un
premier temps des avancées ont eu lieu
ces derniers mois et un projet de
filiale commune a même été envisagé
comme vous nous l'avez indiqué en
octobre dernier pouvez-vous nous faire
un état à date des réflexions menées en
commun avec vos collègues des autres
entreprises de l'audiovisuel public sur
les coopérations en matière de formation
et nous indiquer où en est-on
précisément où on est précisément pardon
le projet de filiale commune pouvez-vous
nous
pouvez pouvons-nous espérer enfin pardon
une avancée significative en 2023 sur ce
sujet de mutualisation de la formation
[Musique]
calendrier sans doute lié aux échéances
électorales qui n'a pas permis
d'arbitrer l'idée comme je vous l'ai dit
qu'on relance maintenant cet arbitrage
mais évidemment plus il y aura de
d'enthousiasme et d'aggle à part de nos
partenaires pour la rejoindre pour les
objectifs que je vais dire plus ce sera
simple pour
telle commune d'arbitré alors l'enjeu
sur la formation initiale j'ai eu
l'occasion de me rappeler ici lors de
mon audition sur le sur le pff mais
également la ministre c'est une des
spécificités que du viol public français
il se trouve pour des raisons
historiques c'est à travers Lina que ça
se perd aujourd'hui que de former chaque
année 300 à 400 jeunes au métier de
l'audiovisuel et du numérique je crois
que dans le contexte actuel de ou
les sources d'information notamment des
enfin voilà de la plateformeisation de
l'information de son déplacement sur des
réseaux sociaux
les amis ces jeunes il y a sans doute
certains qui seront demain les
influenceurs les leaders d'opinion des
réseaux sociaux qui n'existaient pas
encore qui existeront demain qui
prendront la suite de d'un stade de Tik
Tok et là l'idée que voilà parmi ces
gars il y en a qui a été formé dans le
cadre du et avec les valeurs du service
public audiovisuel je crois que
c'est qui sont donc dont on peut donc
espérer en moyenne qui seront un peu
moins complotistes et un peu moins
postes véritiste que ceux qui auront en
phase 2 sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
c'est ça devient ça prend un relief et
une particulier et c'est pour cela
notamment dans sa diminution inclusive
que représente la classe alpha mais pas
que que on est très heureux de pouvoir
ouvrir et partager cette question de
formation initiale avec nos partenaires
sur la formation professionnelle l'enjeu
est un peu différent je vais pas être
trop long mais disons que en tout cas
d'abord il y a quelque chose qui doit
être bien clair c'est que cette filiale
qui rassemblerait donc formation
initiale et professionnelle
en faisant comme on dit au passage un
peu pivoter le modèle parce que pour des
raisons historiques à Ghina
on a commencé par faire de la formation
pro parce que on a hérité du centre de
formation de RTL tout simplement puis il
y a 20 ans un peu presque 20 ans on a
créé de la formation initiale mais
j'aurais sûrement pas fait mieux enfin
bon avec pas beaucoup de synergie on va
dire entre
l'ingénierie pédagogique qui a été très
séparé y compris en termes de terrain
bon c'est à dire on a fait exactement le
contraire de ce que font tous les
centres de formation qui développent la
formation pro sur le socle de la
formation initiale et qui contribue
d'ailleurs à au financement de
l'ensemble voilà donc on est en train
aussi de faire ça en termes
d'organisation interne mais sur la
formation professionnelle
qui sera donc qui serait donc réunis
dans cette filiale avec la formation
initiale pour faire naître aussi entre
ces deux pots synergies qui existent par
tout ailleurs dans tous les grands
centres de formation au métier du
journalisme ou de des techniques
audiovisuelles et numérique la formation
pro il s'agit évidemment pas que soit
défini ailleurs que dans les entreprises
qui rejoindraient cette filiale les
besoins de formation et les plans de
formation pour leur propre salariés on
est vraiment dans un outil de prestation
et l'enjeu au fond il est simple c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il y a une partie
majoritaire très majoritaire même des
budgets de formation
des des de nos partenaires qui sont
confiés à des prestataires privés
c'est évidemment sous réserve que cette
filiale propose pour des tarifs
équivalents de prestations de qualité
équivalente
évidemment c'est c'est de l'argent qui
au lieu de sortir de l'audiovisuel
public cirque restera à l'intérieur et
donc on est dans une synergie de de
immédiate immédiate sachant que l'idée
d'une filiale c'est que précisément
parce que nos partenaires y seraient
associés au capital
évidemment ça permettrait que par
ailleurs est revenu tirer de cette
activité soit aussi CIRFA voilà ça
permet aussi de mutualiser les
éventuelles remontées de enfin voilà que
si c'est donc voilà ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que je
les discussions y compris ces derniers
jours on continuait et je suis plutôt
très optimiste sur la capacité alors je
me dis prudemment parce que d'abord ça
suppose des des informations des
évolutions qui sont qui qui
juridiquement suppose de consulter les
élus du personnel etc mais voilà j'ai
j'ai très bon espoir compte tenu des
échanges qu'on a eu y compris très
récemment
y compris avec nos amis de Radio France
et de France media monde que cette
filiale puisse voir le jour et commencer
à se construire des 2023
merci pour cette information avant de
passer la parole à mes collègues moi je
voudrais m'insérer dans le dans
l'échange et vous poser une question sur
les rapprochements et un en particulier
qui intéresse forcément la chambre des
territoires que nous sommes à savoir le
rapprochement entre France 3 et France
Bleu vous l'avez mentionné l'une et
l'autre depuis plusieurs années des
coopérations existent vous l'avez dit
notamment à travers le regroupement des
matinales et puis le site d'information
commun ces coopérations sont révélées
intéressantes en tout cas vous en êtes
satisfaite même si on le sait elles se
sont heurtées à quelques difficultés
notamment du fait de l'identité forte
des des deux maisons l'idée de
rapprocher encore plus ces deux entités
existent on le sait pour créer ce qui
pourrait être appelé un média public de
proximité
pensez-vous que cette ce média public de
proximité puisse être un élément
important du du des futurs com alors je
parle pas du prolongement du comme sur
devine 23 bien sûr mais le com 2024 2028
qu'elle pourrait être la forme de ce
regroupement est-ce que vous avez
commencé à y réfléchir et est-ce que
pour y parvenir il faut une modification
législative où vous pouvez le faire à
partir du changement de statut des
entreprises
monsieur le Président moi je voudrais
revenir sur ce projet donc je vous
remercie de rappeler déjà tout ce que
nous avons mis en oeuvre évidemment on
pourrait effectivement aller plus loin
et on est en train en train d'en
discuter ce que je voudrais rappeler
c'est que à la fin cette cette
collaboration elle se fait entre des
hommes et des femmes qui doivent être
à l'aise pour poursuivre ses
coopérations aujourd'hui à chaque fois
qu'on dit synergie on dit baisse des
effectifs et baisse du budget
donc vous n'aurez pas l'adhésion des
gens sur le terrain à faire encore des
efforts pour modifier leur pratique
professionnelle pour faire différemment
de ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui pour se
lancer dans un aventure si vous leur
dites au passage on va encore baisser
les effectifs
on a énormément baissé les effectifs sur
France 3 il faut quand même le dire
aujourd'hui je le dis surtout français
vision mais sur France 3 particuliers
avec tout ce qu'on a à faire deux
journaux par jour
enfin voilà il y a une limite et quand
on dit est-ce qu'on est finalement
pléthorique je voudrais rappeler quand
même le coût de l'audiovisuel public par
tête d'habitants notre performance par
rapport à ce coût en se comparant aux
autres services publics européens on a
tous les chiffres donc évidemment on
pourra vous faire passer tout ça donc à
un moment voilà c'est difficile donc je
pense que pour répondre à votre question
il faudra vraisemblablement un texte
législatif parce que ça modifie
profondément nos cahiers des charges et
je maîtrise pas tout à fait ces sujets
là si il a regardé elle
peut-être tu pourras m'aider à répondre
à cette question
en revanche moi je sais qu'il faudra un
cadre clair pour les personnels voilà ça
c'est ça c'est une évidence
je vais compléter la réponse de ma
collègue entre France Bleu et François
ces dernières années on a commencé à
engager des choses qui sont très
importantes et structurantes on a une
coopération éditoriale sur les matinales
communes et il faut savoir que
équipé 44 stations locales
pour faire une émission qui est
retransmise à la télévision c'est un
effort d'investissement de formation de
qui est absolument considérable
hier matin c'était la 27e dans le
Périgord à France Bleu Périgord qui
était inauguré on s'est fixé comme
objectif en 2023 d'aller à 36 donc rien
pour faire les 44 ça nécessite déjà des
efforts et notamment des efforts
financiers parce que c'est une offre
supplémentaire qui fait l'objet
évidemment dans un contexte de réduction
des moyens à la fois du côté de France
télévisé une radio France des
discussions qui sont très précises parce
que on fait tous énormément d'efforts de
chaque côté
il y a une deuxième coopération qui est
une coopération numérique qui est là
aussi est une coopération qui a beaucoup
de sens et
j'en rejoins les propos Delphine Ernotte
il faut que les différentes équipes est
un projet commun un projet éditorial qui
est envie d'avancer le plus naturel
c'est aujourd'hui sur le numérique parce
que il y a énormément de complémentarité
entre ce que produisent chacun des
réseaux
entre France Bleu et France 3 et que
cette complémentarité là c'est une
occasion d'échanger de coordonnées de
faire en sorte de couvrir encore mieux
l'actualité locale et on a tous la
conviction et c'est ça qui nous
rassemble aussi on a la conviction que
c'est ce qu'attendre les Français
c'est-à-dire qu'on voit bien et nous on
voit très bien dans les audiences
numériques
qui étaient celle de France Bleu devenu
ici inattente qui est très fort des
Français les Français
sont demandeurs d'actualité locale ils
sont demandeurs d'une information qui
soit une information de nature
cervicielle ils sont demandeurs d'une
information de solution cette semaine
par exemple on a lancé avec une
infographie sur le numérique ce qu'on
appelle la carte France Bleu qui donne
pour chaque département le
l'augmentation du prix de
une trentaine de produits précisément en
37 et en fonction des départements on
voit que dans certains c'est je vais
très proser mais c'est le steak haché
dans un autre c'est la sauce tomate dans
en fonction voilà c'est sur des
informations qui sont utiles qui sont
concrètes qui sont expliqués et c'est un
service qui est très utile qu'on essaie
de développer et pour le développer
voilà on peut le faire ensemble c'est
déjà un effort qui est important qu'on
essaie de construire
et on a deux antennes qui aujourd'hui
sont différentes France Bleu c'est un
média local c'est la généralise la
proximité c'est le seul de cette nature
là aujourd'hui avec 44 stations locales
France 3
l'information qui est régionalisée je
salue les efforts fait par France
Télévisions parce que c'est une réforme
très importante qui est engagée par
Delphine Ernotte dans cet aspect de
régionalisation mais on a deux modèles
qui sont aujourd'hui éditorialement qui
restent très différent donc on fait
toutes les coopérations qui nous
apparaissent vraiment optimal pour
renforcer le service qu'on rend citoyen
si sur une question législative
c'est certain que si la question qui
était posée
c'est de faire en sorte que les
personnels et le même statut oui ça
passerait par une modification
législative et en tout cas dans ce qu'on
a lancé aujourd'hui ce sont des
coopérations qui sont en cours sur
lesquels c'est beaucoup de travail pour
nos équipes et qui vont beaucoup nous
occuper en 2023
merci David et souligne
merci monsieur le Président merci de
vous exposer
qui me font tout de suite dire qu'à
travers vous
il faut que nous envoyerions
un message très clair à tous ceux qui
font vos succès parce que ce que vous
dites est impressionnant mais ce sont
effectivement des femmes et des hommes
en chair et en os qui le font
souvent les sites en chiffres de
dégraissage ou de plans et
avec beaucoup moins de moyens ils ont pu
faire ça alors ça donne une idée à
certains que on pourrait encore
pousser et faire qu'il y ait encore
moins de moyens parce que vous arrivez à
faire des choses fantastiques
malgré tout cela non moi j'y vois
beaucoup d'abnégation d'amour de leur
métier dans l'audiovisuel public et je
veux qu'on les remercie fortement parce
que c'est impressionnant les chiffres
que vous donnez et ça permet
dans un moment où on a besoin et que
l'information soit une information de
qualité et que les programmes culturels
et autres soient aussi des moyens de
faire fructifier l'intelligence des
Français là où beaucoup de bêtises
s'étale sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
très important donc voilà la première
chose que je voulais vous dire et
ça vient démentir quelque chose
qui avait été quand même planté comme
une épée de Damoclès sur votre tête dès
que
un précédent quinquennat avait commencé
en parlant de honte de la République
quand on parlait du service public donc
vous l'avez démenti et c'est loin d'être
la honte vous êtes une des fiertés de ce
que l'on peut faire dans ce domaine-là
ensuite
je vous dis que il y a un pluralisme
dans la commission culture parce que je
vois votre mission culture amener des
combats communs sur beaucoup de choses
mais c'est aussi une bagarre politique
pour continuer à faire que le service
public soit
préservé vous savez que j'ai été
rapporteur d'une commission d'enquête
sur général la concentration dans les
médias et si vous regardez nos
délibérations puisqu'elles sont en
compte-rendu intégral vous remarquerez
que certains qui disent vivre le service
comparé à cnews en termes de pluralisme
notamment Radio France et je l'ai
dénonçais en disant que on ne pouvait
pas dire de telles choses du service
public qui n'est pas un média d'opinion
et vous savez que vous avez subi ce type
d'attaque qui ont précédé ensuite le
fait de supprimer la redevance que vous
ne remplissiez pas des missions de
pluralie mais vous étiez de parti pris
tout autant que pour un autre bord
politique que distille ces news l'été
donc moi je veux vous dire que ce
soutien aussi sur la façon dont vous
traitez en général
le pluralisme dans dans vos antennes
ma question qui est
toute et tous
aussi un exemple fait que sur les quatre
et trois femmes à la tête de
l'audiovisuel public c'est aussi une de
nos fierté parce que c'est pas dans
beaucoup de services publics de grand
corps d'état ou même de société privée
que c'est le cas
je la question c'est que justement il y
a eu plusieurs centaines de millions
mine de rien quand on cumule qui ont été
retirés du circuit vous avez fait les
performances avant tout dans la
révolution numérique
vous avez su assumer une mutation avec
tout ce que vous avez pu décrire et ça
s'est fait sur fond propre
ça pas été donc c'est aussi quelque
chose qui a retiré du fonctionnement
qu'il pouvait y avoir avant
ma question elle est simple c'est que
est-ce que vous pensez en plus avec la
petite augmentation qui a eu cette année
mais qui est deux fois moins grande que
la prévision d'inflation est-ce que vous
pensez pouvoir assumer ce niveau de
performance parce qu'après il y a les
autres choix c'est-à-dire réduire le
périmètre c'est-à-dire
faire moins etc ce que vous pouvez
est-ce que vous pensez qu'au moins ce
que vous faites aujourd'hui
est possible sans
redynamise de de
vos recettes c'est à dire sans le fait
que à nouveau il y a une trajectoire
d'augmentation notamment question mais
ça peut être dans d'autres domaines pour
les autres dans vos projets
vous pour assurer une présence
internationale à la hauteur des des
conflits et des enjeux parce que ça
coûte plus cher quand il y a la guerre
ça coûte beaucoup plus cher d'envoyer
quelqu'un en terme de protection en
termes etc et c'est pareil pour vous
c'est pareil pour vous mais voilà
vous par exemple pour le pour
l'audiovisuel public la question
concrète c'est
est-ce que vous pouvez même garder le
sport que vous diffusez puisque les
offres on sert Roland Garros
sur le marché est-ce que vous êtes en
capacité de continuer aussi assurer le
service public dans des domaines aussi
fondamentaux où il y a le plus
d'audience en général que comme comme le
sport je sais que le président
est pressé que j'arrête et donc j'arrête
mais je vous pose vraiment la question à
chacun est-ce que je sais qu'à une
tutelle mais vous êtes indépendant vous
l'avez dit
est-ce que vous pensez qu'avec les
moyens d'aujourd'hui
vous pouvez continuer à assumer la même
qualité sans aller réduire un certain
nombre de services que vous
ou de projet ou de projets que vous avez
merci ce que je vous propose parce que
comme le temps passe c'est de regrouper
les questions et puis bien sûr des
répondre après Jérémy baquy merci
monsieur le Président je serais bref à
mon tour je voulais remercier Madame les
présidents mesdames les présidentes et
monsieur le Président pour vos
interventions les mineurs ça lui
également le travail de l'ensemble de
vos équipes pour le travail réalisé et
un travail de bonne facture alors madame
Sarragosse vous le disiez on est dans un
contact un contexte international
extrêmement particulier un contexte de
guerre effectivement ou à ce titre nous
avons besoin effectivement d'avoir une
information une bataille culturelle
extrêmement importantes à l'échelle
européenne à l'échelle
international à ce titre je veux saluer
les forfaits du développement et de la
stratégie de France Télévisions et de
France info sur le numérique je
considère que c'est une bonne chose
c'est que ça participe effectivement de
cela c'était important de le dire il y a
de mon point de vue de batailles
culturelles à monnaie la première c'est
celle de l'information ça a été dit
guerre nuken monter des fascisme des
informations monter des fake news y
compris dans notre pays et pas
simplement à l'international
à ce titre je voulais savoir où Madame
Sarragosse vous avez interpellé sur la
nécessité de ne pas apparaître comme une
chaîne gouvernementale avec les
conséquences que cela pouvait avoir
notamment en Allemagne je voulais savoir
si vous aviez évalué peut-être un peu
les répercussions que ça pourrait avoir
si tel devait être le cas pas simplement
en Allemagne est-ce que on saurait
pénalisé dans d'autres pays et ce que ça
pourrait représenter pour vous en termes
de conséquence l'idée d'une charte
républicaine me semble être
éventuellement une bonne idée à la
condition qu'elle suffise à elle seule à
entre guillemets à déjouer ces pièges là
la deuxième des batailles culturelles de
mon point de vue c'est celle de la
production et notamment des
documentaires
on a la chance d'avoir des documentaire
peut-être de bonne facture dans notre
pays sur un certain nombre de sujets que
ce soit des sujets historiques
animaliers ou tout ce que vous voulez
mais je trouve qu'on est peut-être un
peu en deçà de ce que certains de nos
voisins notamment anglo-saxons sont en
capacité de faire et il me semble
important que cela puisse être
concurrencé je dirais même si je sais
que qu'il faut des moyens pour cela
parce que l'analyse de l'histoire
l'analyse des événements l'analyse d'un
certain nombre de sujets importants
participent à la bataille culturelle
d'un pays comme le nôtre parce que oui
la vision que peut avoir la France des
grands événements historiques n'est pas
nécessairement la même que celle des
Anglais des Allemands ou d'autres
nations
une question d'ailleurs à ce sujet et je
terminerai par là est-ce que d'ailleurs
on n'a pas intérêt à travailler
différemment mais peut-être que vous
pourrez dire ce que ce que vous mettez
en oeuvre sur la question de l'export de
l'ensemble des productions qu'elles
soient documentaire qu'elle soit de
Téléfilm ou de série alors je vois que
certaines choses qui marchent plutôt
bien mais vous ne vouliez pas qu'on
compare à d'autres modèles de
financement notamment l'Allemagne moi je
partage aussi qu'on pourrait avoir
peut-être plus de moyens pour l'audio
vous avez le public en France mais dans
ces pays là y compris en Angleterre ou
en Allemagne il y a une part du
commercial de de liée à l'exportation
d'un certain nombre de choses qui est
élevé je sais ce que ça nécessite y
compris comme moyen mise en place pour
financer ces productions ou autre mais
voilà j'avais une petite question là
dessus je vous remercie Monique de Barco
je vous remercie merci pour tous les
éléments que vous nous avez apporté
moi je serai très brève j'ai
l'impression que c'est une période
transitoire avec la fin de la redevance
qui finalement
c'était pas du tout préparé on voit bien
aujourd'hui
ce qui se passe c'est-à-dire les
difficultés que vous avez l'avenir qui
qui vous attend on n'en sait pas trop
par contre
cette période transitoire c'est aussi le
prolongation de cette ce contrat
d'objectif de moyens d'un an mais
pourquoi faire pour faire quoi pourquoi
parce que dans le sentiment que j'ai
mais je dois dire que c'est un sentiment
je voudrais avoir c'est à dire qu'il se
prépare autre chose et vous l'avez
évoqué vous êtes déjà en synergie pour
travailler ensemble est-ce que c'est une
période transitoire pour préparer une
deuxième étape qui serait celle d'une
fusion d'une structure qui vous
rassemble etc donc je pose cette
question je n'en sais rien mais
je m'interroge sachant que je voudrais
juste madame Ernotte vous avez justement
parlé à un moment donné de trois
scénarios celui du rétrécissement du
statu quo et celui de l'élargissement
qui est votre scénario celui que vous
préférez pouvez-vous un peu développer
cette troisième cette troisième scénario
Catherine Morin de saillie merci
monsieur le Président alors désolé
d'être arrivé en retard donc je n'ai pas
pu entendre l'ensemble de vos
interventions mesdames j'ai entendu
celle de de Laurent vallée donc je vais
essayer de de m'adapter alors j'ai des
questions générales et puis deux trois
questions un peu plus précises
alors que au niveau européen s'engage la
réflexion sur un nouveau texte qui le
médium freedom heart qui vise à
préserver le pluralisme et
l'indépendance des médias dans le marché
unique de l'Union mais également à
compléter les mesures existantes
relatives au marché de de l'audiovisuel
tout cela pour répondre à des phénomènes
constatés sur le sol européen notamment
une liberté des médias battus en brèche
dans certains pays heureusement peu
nombreux mais tout de même qui existent
où on doit combattre aussi
la désinformation
et la manipulation de la formation
ou aussi on doit combattre les
ingérences de puissance étrangère
comment ce texte s'est-il apprécié de
vous au regard des travaux que vous avez
engagés dans le cas de la PFE je vais
m'expliquer vous avez été à l'initiative
madame la Présidente en tant que
présidente de l'URS d'un colloque qui a
rassemblé l'ensemble des entreprises de
l'audio visuel public français mais
également des autres pays européens un
colloque qui a finalement en
anticipation sans doute réfléchie assez
question qui forcément posé la question
des missions
des modalités pour exécuter ses missions
dont des valeurs sur lequel s'appuie
dont l'indépendance mais également des
moyens donc quelle synthèse
pourriez-vous nous faire aujourd'hui
devant notre commission des grandes
leçons
de ces travaux qui ont été menés dans le
cadre de la pfu ou la France évolue
moteur en fait de cette réflexion qui
interroge les moyens mais également les
modèles aussi de financement et les
modèles économiques amenés peut-être à
évoluer dans l'ensemble des États
membres de comment ont-ils évolué et
qu'est-ce que cela a produit ce serait
très intéressé d'entendre vos réponses
des questions peut-être plus précises
cette fois qui concerne pour Radio
France le passage en DAB+ avec un
simulcas avec l'AFM et le diabète plus
qu'il faudra financer en même temps
comment ce chantier peut-il être mené
avec quel moyen quels sont vos défis une
autre question porte sur toujours en
termes de moyens la question des
orchestres parce que aujourd'hui
l'ensemble des orchestres enfants on se
rend compte des difficultés importantes
qui sont liées à la crise et énergétique
et ses conséquences au retour des
publics aux problématiques de de
diffusion donc pouvez-vous nous éclairer
c'est un élément important du du projet
et je rattacha aussi au projet de
Culturebox que nous avons appelé de tous
nos vœux dans le cadre de la
pérennisation suite l'expérience
positive du du covid tout ça nécessite
aussi des moyens en amont sur le terrain
qui permet aussi la valorisation de tout
ce qui se passe dans la France entière
des moyens de captation d'enregistrement
pouvez-vous nous en dire plus est-ce que
vous vous trouvez face aussi à certaines
difficultés par rapport à ces missions
qui vous sont également confiées dans le
cadre de contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens je me rappelle que votre
commission plusieurs collègues avaient
insisté sur l'importance de la diffusion
musicale voilà quelques questions
encore une fois
je tiens à le dire regrettant que la
suppression de la redevance se soit fait
dans ces conditions peu sécurisantes
pour l'avenir
personnel je m'inquiète
de ce que sera la ressource que j'espère
pérenne et dynamique pour les le portage
des missions que vous avez à effectuer
dans le contexte qu'on vient énoncer
justement de grands problèmes à résoudre
et dont s'empare l'Europe a juste titre
Alexandra borchio Fontain
merci monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues mesdames et
messieurs merci pour vos interventions
et votre présence ma question s'adresse
plus particulièrement à madame la
Présidente de France Télévisions
je suis élue des Alpes-Maritimes
ancienne journaliste je souhaitais ici
donc vous interroger sur un sujet local
mais qui préoccupe vos salariés et les
élus de mon département il s'agit du
projet de déménagement des locaux de
France 3 Côte d'Azur d'Antibes à Nice
qui est cristallise un certain nombre de
tensions que ce soit du côté de tous les
syndicats de salariés mais aussi des
maires parlementaires des
Alpes-Maritimes et du Var un projet qui
est contesté pour trois raisons majeures
le motif de sécurité l'utilisation
d'argent public et l'équité territoriale
de service public je vais m'expliquer
donc à la suite des intempéries
exceptionnelles en 2015 la cave de la
station de France 3 Côte d'Azur a été
inondée des travaux de sécurisation du
site ont été réaliser ce qui a permis
d'ailleurs d'écarter définitivement et
heureusement toute inondation des
sous-sols le bâtiment a même été désigné
par la DDTM comme site refuge en cas de
nouvelles inondations ensuite dans vos
déclarations que vous indiquez l'absolu
nécessité de réaliser des restrictions
budgétaires pour France Télévisions à
hauteur de 40 à 50 millions d'euros hors
ce projet de déménagement va coûter près
de 20 millions d'euros on peut donc
légitimement se demander dans cette
période essentielle d'économie d'argent
public pourquoi engager des dépenses
alors que à Antibes France Télévisions
et propriétaire les salariés je crois
réclament des moyens pour les programmes
pas de nouveau locaux et puis enfin
l'emplacement actuel permet aux
journalistes de garantir une équité
territoriale essentielle à mon sens
entre le Var et les Alpes-Maritimes donc
en conclusion pour faire suite au
courrier d'ailleurs de mes collègues qui
vous ont été adressés aux motions aussi
adoptées pour éviter un tel projet
madame la Présidente je souhaite tout
simplement connaître votre position en
espérant qu'elle est évoluée depuis aux
dernières annonces
je vous remercie l'embarcos
merci beaucoup en fait c'était une
plutôt une remarque qu'une question à
part une question concernant madame
Saragosse vous avez tout à l'heure par
les bien évidemment
de nos difficultés en Afrique j'aurais
voulu vous reveniez dessus parce qu'on
est fait on sait que
l'anglais l'anglais et j'allais dire les
pays anglophones prennent beaucoup
d'ascendants et on peut en être
quinquiet dans nos pays
en général
pourtant très traditionnellement
francophone donc si vous aviez en effet
un plan entre guillemets pour essayer de
changer ça j'avais le même question que
le président concernant mais évidemment
le rapprochement
France Bleu et France 3 et d'une manière
plus générale je m'adresse et à Sylvie
et à Delphine Ernotte pardon l'orange
n'est pas de question forcément pour
vous
concernant la musique
j'appelle votre attention que vous savez
que le milieu du de la musique et des
orchestres sont vraiment en très grande
difficultés et de pouvoir avoir encore
la possibilité
d'avoir sur des émissions notamment
France Télévisions des orchestres
payants je sais que vous êtes c'est
compliqué pour vous mais je l'ai vu pour
le dernier grand échiquier au château de
Versailles vous aviez eu la possibilité
de bénéficier de l'orchestre de Château
de Versailles mais c'est vrai que
d'autres orchestres
veulent continuer à pouvoir avoir des
prestations
sybiles ces différents vous avez les
orchestres de Radio France mais sur le
question de la musique en général est-ce
que vous pourriez en dire un mot parce
que vous avez aussi une certaine manière
cette mission dans l'audiovisuel public
d'également de continuer à faire vivre
tous ces orchestres privés qui sont en
grande difficulté actuellement voilà
et enfin Michel logier oui
mais c'est pas grave mesdames les
présidentes bonsoir monsieur le
Président juste dans un an et demi nous
allons vivre un événement historique et
les Jeux Olympiques donc je voulais
savoir respectivement ce que vous avez
prévu dans vos budgets pour vivre cet
événement pour le faire vivre et est-ce
que peuvent vous les Jeux Olympiques
c'est une chance pour l'audiovisuel
public ou c'est une contrainte
financière
c'est une question journalistique
évidemment puisqu'elle est
journalistique
je ne sais pas comment voulez-vous
organiser dans pour les réponses
qui commencent peut-être répondre sur le
sport à la fois sur
la question des droits sportifs de
l'évolution de ses droits et puis aussi
des JO bon tout d'abord ce que je veux
dire c'est sur le sport on est toujours
heureux même de payer cher pour des
droits sportifs parce que le sport est
essentiel à notre mission de rassembler
de créer du commun
positif pour l'ensemble de la nation
donc oui les JO à Paris c'est beaucoup
plus cher que les JO d'habitude mais on
est tellement heureux et tellement fier
de porter les valeurs de l'olympisme
pendant ces trois semaines plus les
trois semaines d'après puisque vous
savez que on est aussi diffuseur des
Jeux paralympiques donc c'est du bonheur
le sport vraiment et on est fier de
porter toutes ces valeurs alors après
c'est vrai qu'il y a une question
économique parce qu'on a vu ces
dernières années les peut pas sportifs
partir en flèche nos moyens des cendres
donc c'est quand même un problème on a
réussi jusqu'ici à plutôt baisser les
droits sportifs à l'exception des JO de
Paris ça c'est un peu une année enfin
quatre années particulières parce que
vous savez qu'on étale le cou des JO sur
4 ans
mais on a quand même bien renégocié les
choses maintenant maintenant
la question n'est plus tant de la
concurrence entre nous et les autres
acteurs de l'audiovisuel privé qui on
peut ou proue les mêmes fourchettes
d'investissement que nous mais c'est la
concurrence avec les plateformes
américaines Amazon sur Roland Garros et
là honnêtement leurs moyens n'ont rien à
voir avec les nôtres donc si demain
Amazon décide d'acheter parce que c'est
ça qu'il s'agit c'est dans ce sens là
des droits sportifs qui sont de
tradition sur le service public soit pas
par quels moyens on pourra résister et
c'est bien ça le problème en vrai et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on a je
crois et essayer d'attirer l'attention
sur sur le décret des événements
d'importance majeure parce que c'est la
seule façon au fond de protéger l'accès
gratuit au sport parce qu'à la fin c'est
de ça qu'on parle l'accès gratuit de
tous nos concitoyens au sport qui se
passent chez eux avec leurs athlètes
à côté de chez eux et qui va être
privatisé alors Amazon ou un beau dire
que c'est gratuit ça n'est pas gratuit
rien n'est gratuit dans ce monde
commercial donc voilà donc moi je milite
en tout cas pour qu'on protège l'accès
gratuit au sport
[Musique]
le micro le micro le coup a baissé ces
dernières années sur les autres
compétitions on a réussi avec Roland
Garros dans le nouvel appel d'offres
à la hauteur pour le prendre parce
qu'Amazon get
parce que c'est pas nous on va remettre
un pli comme la dernière fois c'était
des c'était des enchères à un tour
Roland-Garros la dernière fois on a
remis un pli sur il y avait trois lots
on a remis un pli sur à l'eau et après
je ne sais pas ce qui a mis Amazon par
exemple c'est voilà donc c'était pas une
négociation de très agréée c'était un
système d'enchères je ne sais pas
comment va avoir lieu
cet appel on nous on est plutôt
favorable à ce qui est des discussions
qui soient qui sont âme
mais ça n'est pas dans mes mains c'est
dans les mains de la Fédération
Française de Tennis
tac je cassais l'ordre des prises de
parole si une ville
elle t'a pas fini non mais moi comme
vous voulez parce que je trouvais que je
termine vite pardon
c'est en fonction des questions
Catherine Morin de saillie m'a
interpellé sur le midi
en fait oui on est fait on est très
favorable globalement au sein de romedia
fredomac sachant que les Allemands sont
un peu réticents ils craignent en fait
que l'Europe prenne trop de poids dans
ce qui pour eux doit être encore régulé
et gérer nationalement c'est ça la
petite la petite subtilité mais
néanmoins ce qu'on peut voir comme très
positif dans Midi à fredom Act c'est une
chose essentielle pour nous service
public c'est le les conditions de
l'indépendance réaffirmée dans le média
freedomingue ces conditions
d'indépendance c'est la gouvernance
c'est un financement qui ne dépendent
pas de l'humeur des autres et surtout
c'est la prévisibilité de ce financement
donc ça c'est écrit noir sur blanc dans
le média freinomax et donc c'est ce que
l'Europe considère comme un service
public indépendant on n'y est pas tout à
fait nous en France donc on va sans
drapeau mais on y est pas aujourd'hui
c'est ça que je veux dire on n'a pas de
prévisibilité du financement le moins on
voulait profiter du milieu africains
pour réaffirmer ce qu'on avait essayé de
pousser dans le 2 le DSMA le digital
marketact c'est-à-dire l'importance de
mettre en avant sur les télés connectées
sur les télécommandes les contenus
d'intérêt général et sur les enceintes
connectées les contenus d'intérêt
généraux que nous sommes bon on l'a pas
obtenu sur le DSMA parce qu'il nous
avait été répondu à l'époque c'est c'est
surtout les marchés c'est pas propre à
l'audiovisuel donc on peut pas mettre de
telles clauses on s'est dit midi on va
en profiter pour rappeler l'importance
de la Providence et là on n'a pas été
tout à fait entendu donc on revient un
peu à la charge sur ces questions-là
très rapidement parce que on pourrait en
parler mais je serais ravi de venir vous
voir et d'en parler plus largement
ce qui m'intéressait de savoir c'est
dans le cadre de la PFE le débat qui a
eu lieu avec des audiovisées publiques
européennes en France sur les modèles
économiques et de financement la façon
d'assurer les missions l'adéquation de
l'émission et des moyens
en fait il y a pas de il y a rien de tel
dans le média freedomac
si je comprends pas la question avec le
milieu africains parce qu'il a nourri
dans le la perspective de garantir la
liberté de la presse le pluralisme et
l'indépendance des médias notamment et
du visuels ça se nourrit forcément d'une
réflexion sur les moyens les modèles
économiques et de financement qui
peuvent permettre aussi ces sujets donc
je vais savoir ce qui était ressorti des
débats dans le cas de la PFE ou été
raffirmé cette nécessité de
l'indépendance
on peut y revenir en tout cas
disons que nous on peut rappeler les
principes et c'est ce qu'on a et ce
qu'on rappelle au niveau européen et ses
principes dont on avait des battu c'est
à dire une gouvernance qui soit bien
instaurée qui ne que la nomination et la
démission du patron de l'audiovisuel
public en question ne soit pas le fait
du gouvernement mais d'une instance
séparés enfin je peux relister tout ça
si vous voulez mais j'ai peur de prendre
le temps de mal et Christine
le fait d'avoir une prévisibilité des
ressources et de ressources qui soient à
la hauteur des missions qui sont
confiées et sur une période de temps
suffisante pour pouvoir anticiper en
fait
les actions de l'entreprise à l'instant
T et ses conséquences dans le futur
j'ai oublié sans doute des choses après
il y a plusieurs modèles qui existent en
Europe
voiture il y a un modèle de redevance il
y a un modèle de
taxes de recettes affectées et il y a
aussi des modèles de budgétisation mais
qui sont là beaucoup plus ferme par
révisible annuellement et qui sont
inscrits un peu en dur dans des dans des
dans des engagements
pluriannuels importants voilà on est les
quelques budgétisations qui sont qui ont
sont arrivés c'est le cas de l'Espagne
en fait c'est des tequins prélude à la
coupe pure et simple des budgets de
l'audiovisuel public donc en gros les
pays budget budgétistes pour couper les
ressources voilà clairement on a on a
tous ces exemples là pardon j'étais trop
longue excuse-moi vous m'avez vous
m'avez demandé aussi quel était mon
troisième scénario l'élargissement en
fait je pense que dans le temps qui est
le nôtre avec quand même des inquiétudes
qui m'ont très très fortes sur la
maîtrise de notre espace médiatique y
compris les réseaux sociaux à plusieurs
titres on voit Twitter qui sera
peut-être plus du tout régulé alors
heureusement on a la régulation
européenne qui nous protège mais enfin
tout de même on sent des choses pas la
philosophie libertarienne qui est quand
même pas
qui peut être un peu angoissante pour
nous Européens on voit d'autres réseaux
sociaux qui prennent quand même beaucoup
de l'attention de nos enfants dans
toutes les données par ton shield
il faut pas être naïf non plus par
rapport à ça on peut aussi considérer
que certains médias dérivent vers des
médias d'opinion alors là c'est un débat
certes mais enfin il sera tranché en
tout cas par la régulation donc avoir un
espace préservé réellement indépendant
ou le débat peut avoir lieu en fait ou
des gens qui sont pas d'accord peuvent
discuter entre eux sans que ça se tourne
au pugilat ou ou à la violence verbale
qu'on accepte d'avoir des désaccords de
les partager et d'échanger des idées ça
semble est-ce que ça semble important
voilà sur cet axe donc informationnel
sur le deuxième axe qui est plus
culturel est-ce que on cède le pas
finalement on lâche la création
française européenne la culture
française parce que on va se parler
franchement s'il y a plus de service
public
bah il y aura plus d'orchestre
de Radio France il y aura plus de
Culturebox il y aura plus de théâtre à
la télé il y aura plus de cinéma
français à la télé il y aura plus de
fiction française à la télé on va se
parler franchement voilà donc c'est un
choix qui est politique en fait on peut
imaginer un monde comme ça bien sûr
qu'on peut l'imaginer mais c'est presque
un choix de société donc il n'appartient
pas aux dirigeants que nous sommes j'ai
exprime mon avis moi je pense que on
voit quand même et d'ailleurs l'UR avait
fait un rapport que le niveau du service
public audiovisuel et niveau de
démocratie était strictement corrélé
donc ça dit un peu quel type de société
on veut demain en réalité et si on
souhaite une démocratie qui fonctionne
qui respire avec cette des gens pas
d'accord et à la fin tout le monde qui
tombe sur le service public parce que
quand je dis toujours à mes équipes en
période électorale si tout le monde vous
engueule c'est que tout va bien le jour
où il y a quelqu'un qui vous engueule
pas c'est que vous avez un problème bon
je vous rassure alors tout le monde nous
a gueulé hein donc voilà donc tout va
bien voilà personne n'a considéré qu'il
était favorisé tout le monde a considéré
qu'il était défavorisé donc c'est que
les choses doivent être à peu près
équilibrées d'une certaine manière voilà
donc en fait je pense que c'est c'est
une vision politique de de l'audiovisuel
public qu'il faut avoir et qui nous
dépasse
vous m'avez posé la question de pourquoi
ne pas profiter des exportations etc bon
c'est une très bonne remarque parce
qu'effectivement ça représente sur les 5
milliards de la BBC que je citais tout à
l'heure un milliard vient de leur
capacité à exporter mais parce que la
BBC possède ce qu'il fabrique nous
depuis la loi de 86 ça nous est interdit
donc même si on faisait un documentaire
animalier à 3 millions l'épisode où à 30
millions l'épisodes comme la BBC qui
sont magnifiques demeurant ben on
pourrait pas les vendre il nous
appartiendrait pas voilà et on aurait
une part coproduction dont on a bien du
mal à tirer quelques recettes voilà donc
en fait on a cet axe là qui n'est qui
n'est pas qui n'est pas tout à fait
possible
j'ai bien conscience que c'est un vrai
problème Antibes ceci étant dit il y a
eu deux inondations j'y suis moi allé
personnellement à chaque fois et j'ai
mis les bottes et honnêtement je me suis
fait peur un parce que c'est une zone
inondable parce que vous avez raison de
dire qu'il y avait des équipements
techniques qui a des gens qui ont pas
évacué alors que alors qu'on leur
demandait d'évacuer parce que les gens
chez nous ils sont tellement investis de
leur mission d'information que il reste
jusqu'au bout donc moi j'ai eu peur je
trouve que c'est pas raisonnable de
rester dans une zone inondable je vous
le dis franchement en tant que moi moi
responsable de la santé de la sécurité
des salariés et ben je suis pas
tranquille donc je préfère qu'on se
relocalise alors après je sais tous les
débats donc on n'est pas fermé à
réfléchir non pas à changer complètement
nos plans en tout cas restera pas anti
si c'est ça dans le lieu là ça c'est sûr
ça c'est sûr moi je m'y oppose fermement
je suis responsable de la Santé Sécurité
je reste pas en zone inondable point et
je l'ai vu moi je l'ai vu avec mes
bottes et en plus on sait tous que
entre nous avec le réchauffement
climatique les tornades les inondations
elles vont pas aller en s'amusant donc
je pense qu'il faut être raisonnable sur
ces sujets là en revanche trouver des
solutions pour les personnels qui soient
peut-être un peu plus Adobe un peu plus
intelligente ça on est en train de
regarder voilà
et je ne sais le souci politique que ça
peut poser voilà
je croyais que tu répondais à la
question de David insuline justement sur
le la question d'abord vous avez été
deux à saluer les équipes et je voudrais
redire en effet et Delphine vient de
dire que c'est pas tout à fait un métier
ce qu'ils font c'est une vocation c'est
et merci de les avoir salués et je
voudrais faire mon tour et quand tu
David a souligne demandé si ça allait
vers 7 et si on avait pas besoin de plus
parce qu'on faisait toujours plus avec
moi je voudrais juste préciser que moi
j'ai essayé de dire dans mon propos
liminaire mais comme Catherine moradetci
était pas là je le redis que j'avais
besoin d'une recette relais avec de
l'aide publique au développement j'ai
même dit 4 x 5 tout ça et que il fallait
une recette affectée dynamique et
pérenne et je crois qu'on l'a tout dit
et que ça on avait un peu peur après
2024 là donc on a et je vous ai même
demandé si vous pouviez déjà avoir une
décision de principe que je perde pas la
fréquence FM à Berlin donc et du coup
sur la fréquence FM à Berlin je ne préf
même pas formulé le risque ça représente
parce que je suis superstitieuse que
j'ai beau touché du bois ici je ne
préfère pas le dire pour pas que ça se
produise mais ce qui est clair c'est que
alors notre indépendance évidemment
qu'elle est pas seulement liée à notre
financement nous ici c'est symbolique à
l'international et c'est un couple
ici je voudrais aussi redire que la
déontologie des équipes journalistiques
françaises en général je connais pas
tous les journalistes français mais je
veux dire que la déontologie de l'idée
de l'info qu'on se fait dans les écoles
de journaliste dans ce pays la liberté
de l'info c'est un bien vraiment très
précieux et rare et que et que donc nous
par exemple on a une commission
déontologie on a une charte de
déontologie je fais je dis nous mais
c'est tout le service public et que
c'est ça d'abord l'indépendance qui a
les chevilles au corps de chaque
journaliste mais qu'en plus la loi nous
protège mais qu'en plus la redevance
nous protège ou plus exactement elle est
une recette affectée nous protège les
modes de nomination et c'est dans le
média freedom actes et c'est ce que dans
le colloque qui avait organisé Delphine
tous les services publics ont dit donc
c'est tout un faisceau et on en a besoin
parce qu'on est crédible sur le plan
international si on est indépendant
sinon on sert pas à grand-chose donc
l'indépendance c'est notre raison d'être
quelque part
alors on va la question c'était l'or
darkos
sur les difficultés alors non non alors
les difficultés francophonie il y a pas
de problème particulier avec la
francophonie l'anglophonie prend pas
particulièrement le dessus
oui mais alors dans l'Afrique anglophone
nous ce qu'on constate c'est qu'on est
de plus en plus distribué regarder aimer
etc donc ça c'est déjà un point France
24 fait un tabac en anglais puisque
fRANCE 24 est en anglais en Afrique
anglophone
sur l'Afrique francophone ce la
nouveauté pour nous et ce qui est très
important c'est de parler les langues
africaines les gens ne sont pas toujours
francophones c'est pas une langue
maternelle toujours ils ne sont pas
toujours scolarisés mais quand on parle
leur langue ce qui est un signe de
respect essentiel et bien on leur donne
une marge d'accès aux Français et
derrière on a le RFI en français facile
on a le talisman brisé qui permet depuis
la langue africaine d'aller vers le
français de manière réciproque et dans
le respect et la richesse du
plurilinguisme qui est la signature de
notre média et l'honneur du service
public international voilà donc ce que
je voudrais dire aussi c'est que nos
résultats en Afrique francophones sont
mais sans commune mesure avec les
résultats de BBC en anglais en Afrique
anglophone on est le double le plus du
double
donc je le dis pour qu'on soit un peu
fier de nous parce qu'en général on est
parfois considéré comme arrogant mais
rarement comme content de nous donc
soyons contents et pas arrogant parce
qu'on le mérite voilà je laisse assimile
le soin de
merci moi je voudrais commencer par
répondre à la question du sénateur
je suis insoline sur notre situation
financière en 2023 nous sommes sortis
d'une période d'économie de baisse
importante de notre ressource
mais qui
produit des effets qui sont durables
effectivement faire plus avec moi
puisque nous avons tous développé des
projets de coopération qui était des
offres supplémentaires on la fait en
faisant des économies donc ça nécessite
des réorganisations des plantes de
départ parce que de nos entreprises à
Radio France ce n'est que de la
production interne donc quand nous
faisons les économies on se sépare de
s'alarer de la Radio France donc ce sont
des efforts qui sont très importants
aujourd'hui c'est dont on a besoin en
2023 on a
une évolution positive de notre budget
donc c'est une évolution qui est
importante pour nous
nous ce qui est plus important pour nous
aujourd'hui c'est la question de la
prévisibilité
la dynamique et la prévisibilité les
deux qui sont essentielles on a évoqué à
plusieurs reprises qu'est-ce qu'elle
sera le com 2024 2028 monsieur le
Président vous m'avez posé la question
concernant les réseaux France Bleu
France 3 madame
Monique de Marco m'avait posé la
question aussi qu'est-ce qui se passera
plus tard c'est très compliqué pour nous
de pouvoir se projeter sans avoir l'idée
d'une trajectoire financière c'est pas
du tout le même projet et comme la très
bien dit des finernut aujourd'hui c'est
pas la même chose de dire à nos équipes
vous coopérer pour faire des économies
supprimées des emplois ou vous coopérer
pour développer une offre supplémentaire
investir faire de la recherche donc il
faut que on ait ce cadre là qui est
absolument essentiel parce que ce n'est
pas du tout le même projet on ne fera
pas la même chose on a fait des efforts
énormes qui font qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes un des services publics
audiovisuel en Europe sans doute le plus
productif nous ces dernières années sur
les économies que nous en avons que nous
avons faites 70% sur les frais de
structure
et les personnels qui
a le plus supporté les réorganisations
ce sont sur les fonctions supports et
administratives donc de manière à
préserver l'offre nous n'avons pas fait
et vous les offres on en a on a fait
évoluer quelques offres on a supprimé
les locales de FIP on a réduit les
effectifs du cœur des orchestres donc il
y a des offres qui ont été touchés à
préserver l'intégrité des 7 chaînes des
44 locales des formations de musicales
donc ce sont des efforts qui sont quand
même très importants et on parle depuis
là à quelques minutes et Marie-Christine
l'a très bien dit on vit un moment de
dérèglement de la formation de guerre
informationnelle on sait à quel point
les fausses informations sont viralistes
de plus en plus fortement désormais avec
les réseaux sociaux et il y a un secteur
dans lequel qui a le palmarès en terme
de fausses informations c'est la santé
donc ça veut dire que sur des éléments
d'information qui sont vitaux
aujourd'hui on sait que c'est là qui a
le plus de fausses informations qui
circulent donc il y a un besoin de média
de confiance crédible dans lequel les
Français ont confiance pour savoir c'est
assez faire vacciner
quel type de traitement adopter comment
réagir
contenu de la situation
énergétique et des économies qui sont à
faire pour
l'ensemble de la collectivité il faut
qu'il y ait des médias qui le portent et
des médias dans lesquels ils ont
confiance et faire une information de
qualité être présent non seulement sur
nos antennes mais diffuser de plus en
plus partout sur le numérique parce
qu'en fait on est aujourd'hui dans un
moment où c'est pas simplement une
guerre de position c'est une guerre de
mouvement faut être présent sur les
réseaux puisque c'est là que circule les
fausses informations ça veut dire éditer
nos informations ça veut dire être très
présent devenir nous-mêmes des médias
sociaux et ça ce sont des métiers de
nouveaux ce sont des investissements
nouveaux et nécessairement ce sont des
choix à faire pour notre pays une marque
comme comme info c'est une marque
aujourd'hui qui inspire confiance qui
voit moi après moi ces auditeurs ces
internautes augmentaient parce que c'est
une marque dans laquelle les Français en
confiance je pense que c'est un actif
stratégique pour notre pays aujourd'hui
c'est la même chose sur les questions de
culture la question a été évoquée sous
différentes formes lors d'Archos a parlé
de nos orchestres madame Morin des
saillie on a parlé également sur la
question de la musique nous jouons
plusieurs rôles aujourd'hui nous portons
la diversité culturelle la diversité des
artistes et surtout des artistes
français s'il n'y avait pas un service
public qui porte autant une diversité
des artistes français et toute une
partie de la scène française
n'existerait pas et la question qui est
devant nous c'est est-ce qu'on veut que
nos enfants en grandissant continuent
d'avoir des artistes français avec
lesquels ils grandissent il faut qu'il y
ait des services publics qui est pour
mission est pour rôle de favoriser ces
artistes là on voit à quel point sur les
différentes plateformes de streaming la
répartition de la rémunération en fait
ne permet pas certains artistes de vivre
parce que le système est fait de manière
à concentrer les écoutes et donc les
flux de revenus sur un nombre limité
d'artistes il y a uniformiser aussi les
goûts nous ce qu'on essaie de faire au
quotidien sur nos différentes chaînes
c'est au contraire de pousser la
diversité c'est d'accompagner
l'émergence d'accompagner les artistes
dans la durée plutôt que les carrés
artistiques jetables qui font que comme
les mouchoirs ça dure des espaces de
d'une chanson d'un tube ou de quelques
vidéos donc c'est un sujet qui est
majeur et ça vaut aussi pour le
patrimoine le patrimoine c'est ce qui
fait le ciment d'une nation quand nous
orchestre jouent des éléments du
patrimoine français et européen
puisqu'on a un orchestre d'orchestre qui
joue les éléments du patrimoine musical
français qui est très important
l'Orchestre Philharmonique lui apporte
en plus la création soutient beaucoup de
création nous sommes un des premiers
acteurs de financement de la création
dans le domaine de la musique
symphonique en France c'est des éléments
très importants de la culture et de sa
transmission et on voit aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs qu'on touche beaucoup les
familles c'est un développement sur
lequel on insiste beaucoup on essaie
vraiment de toucher le public familial
et on voit un désir de transmission des
parents auprès de leurs enfants sur ce
patrimoine à l'égal de du patrimoine
artistique dans d'autres secteurs la
littérature la peinture le théâtre donc
ce sont des éléments de notre histoire
de notre
histoire commune qui sont très
importants et sur lesquels on le fait il
a encore c'est certain que ce sont des
investissements on essaie de le faire en
étant
utile nos orchestres tournent partout en
France et surtout on essaie avec nos
antennes de faire en sorte de donner à
voir ce qui se passe partout en France
franchement musique capte énormément
d'événements partout en France pour être
présent là où il y a des festivals là où
il y a des formations régionales parce
qu'on a le souci de soutenir les
orchestres régionaux et Madame Morin
dessailler non c'est
responsabilités en termes de Musique et
de soutien des orchestres le sait on
prend vraiment à cœur cette émission là
aussi et on le fait également comme
diffuseur
comme lors d'Archos le questionnait sur
la problématique de la captation et
l'enregistrement je pense qu'on devrait
aller sans doute tout le monde on a
beaucoup innové ces dernières années
grâce à Delphine c'est à dire qu'on a
plus de concerts qu'on a fait en commun
qu'on avait demandé je pense que on a
sans doute la capacité d'aller plus loin
on en a le souhait ce sont des éléments
aussi de patrimoine le 14 juillet c'est
un concert sous la Tour Eiffel qu'on
fait ensemble qui a une audience qui est
fantastique et qui cette année était
diffusée dans 50 pays c'est le deuxième
concert de musique classique le plus vu
au monde après le concert du Nouvel An
de Vienne c'est 50 pays c'est un élément
de la culture française qui est visible
partout on le fait parce qu'il y a cette
puissance là cumulé de l'orchestre du la
production ou du visuel et donc c'est à
l'honneur de notre pays de pouvoir faire
ça ça donne une image qui est très forte
sur le DAB+ qui était une question de
Madame Morin des saillie moi j'ai en
tête ce qu'a fait le gouvernement
anglais qui a lancé en 2020 en 2021 une
étude avec l'ensemble des acteurs de la
radio et de l'audio en Grande-Bretagne
pour voir quel serait l'évolution des
modes de distribution de la radio et
justement ce qu'ils ont mis en évidence
c'est que le média radio sera un média
qui continuerait durablement des
d'écouter en direct c'est une différence
par rapport à la télévision c'est-à-dire
que toutes les projections vont vers un
maintien de l'écoute en direct du média
radio parce que c'est un média qui
accompagne notamment en mobilité et donc
l'écoute du direct est majeur et le DAB
est une modalité aujourd'hui sur
laquelle nous devons rattraper notre
retard par rapport aux autres pays
européens parce que dans les autres pays
sont beaucoup plus avancés que nous sur
le DAB ce qui veut dire que quand on
discute avec les constructeurs
automobiles eux ce qu'ils ont en tête
c'est le système qui vont vendre partout
sur le continent européen un système
hybride FM dab et IP dans les zones qui
sont équipées vous pouvez le recevoir en
IP donc il faut que la France progresse
parce que sinon on aura beaucoup de
difficultés à discuter avec les acteurs
qui sont des acteurs non pas nationaux
mais européen voire mondiaux et danser
dans cette perspective là qu'il faut
anticiper l'évolution du DAB par rapport
à d'autres coûts un double coup de
diffusion n'est pas tenable dans la
durée c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement britannique a rassemblé
l'ensemble des acteurs pour voir avec
eux dans la durée comment faire en sorte
que les coûts ne s'additionnent pas mais
qu'à un moment donné
ce soit vertueux pour tous l'écosystème
et je rappellerai que le DAB est moins
coûteux que la FM il est plus sobre et
énergétiquement donc plus vertueux dans
un monde où les préoccupations
environnementales vont devoir accroître
et en plus c'est le meilleur qualité de
son
ce qui pour le public aussi est un
avantage très important donc j'espère
qu'on arrivera à continuer à le
développer très fortement et à
s'entendre pour dessiner à quoi
ressemblerait la distribution de la
radio dans les prochaines années et ça
il faut derrière absolument qu'on ait
une vraie stratégie nationale sur le
sujet
merci mais mesdames les présidents
monsieur le Président vous voulez
répondre juste à la question
non du du documentaire qui a été utilisé
pardon Delphine aurait pu en parler
évidemment le service public est le
financeur majeur du genre documentaire
en France France télévison nous a mis de
d'artefrance évidemment ils sont aussi
des diffuseurs via leurs antennes et via
leur plateforme je rappelle simplement
que par ailleurs c'est le genre le plus
représenté en unitaire sur Malga gamme
et la plateforme de streaming de Vina
avec plus de 2000 documentaires de
patrimoine mais pas que parce qu'il est
alimenté en permanence par une offre de
documentaire frais ce que produit ou
coproduit la mais également
d'autres que nous acquérons dans le
cadre de catalogue et ce qui fait de
Malga la première plateforme de
streaming de documentaire en France et
un acteur majeur donc de l'exploitation
dite suivie des œuvres du siècle
documentaire en effet c'est sur ma gaine
j'ai noté votre position formelle de
principe à ce que ça explique propose
des offres payantes bon j'ai le regret
de vous rappeler que United donc voilà
nous on est industriel et commercial si
vous nous remplacez 50000 x 12 x 2,99
par une ressource pérenne et visible
j'aurais grand plaisir à mettre
Madeleine en gratuit voilà merci
beaucoup
merci beaucoup vous êtes aux autres
de ces réponses très précises